improve your flutter skills by building
a Google Docs clone you'll also learn
more about node.js Express sockets
mongodb and more Ravon ronawat is your
teacher ravana has created a bunch of
popular tutorials and he is an excellent
teacher in this tutorial we are going to
build Google Docs clone using flutter
and node.js this course is designed for
beginners and node.js and no prior
knowledge of JavaScript is required we
will learn how to authenticate users
with Google keep the user logged in
create rest apis to display and create
new documents build a powerful routing
system to share link of our documents
and establish socket connection to allow
users to collaborate with each other
they can type color bold italicize chain
size and much more simultaneously
prerequisite for this course is having a
basic knowledge of flutter for State
Management we will be using riverpod
before we get into this video I'd like
to invite you all to our Discord server
link is mentioned in the description
below we will start off by creating a
flutter project so we'll go to the
visual studio code and in the empty
project here we will click on command
shift p and then click on flutter new
project option then we are going to
generate a application so we can click
over here and then we need to assign the
folder where we need to store this so we
can go to the desktop and your we will
just create a new folder called docs
clone flutter
then click on Create and then we can
select this folder to create the project
end now we also need to name this
project again we will just name this
docs clone flutter and then click on
enter
here you can see flutter create is being
run
and here you can see our project is
ready we need to start running it now
just to test our application we can
obviously run it so I'm going to run it
on web
I'll just click on run and run it
without debugging let's wait for it to
know if we have successfully set up our
application so our application has
started and if you're if you see it our
web version is running
great now let's try to remove everything
all the boilerplate code so I'm just
going to grab all of it from here remove
it out all the comments from here
and here I'm going to create a new
folder called screens here we will
create our very first screen called the
login screen this login screen is going
to be very simple it's just going to
consist of a single button in the center
which is the Google button so let's
import material dot then create a
stateless widget and call this login
screen here we are going to return a
scaffold and let's just return that so
that we can see an empty screen and no
this is working
we'll go to the main.dot file again
and here
import login screen we also remove this
comment and let's see if and you can see
a blank white screen showing up great
that's exactly what we wanted now what
we want is in the center a button
showing up with a Google icon here and
then a button and a text saying sign in
with Google so to do that we will go to
the login screen and in here in the body
we'll pass in a center a center widget
because you want it in the center then
we will have a child and now we want an
elevated button with an icon as you've
seen in the picture already
we are not going to use the normal
elevated button no we want elevated
button dot icon because we need to pass
in an icon it's not necessarily an icon
because I can here accepts a return data
type of widget we can pass in a widget
it doesn't necessarily have to be icon
or icon data
so here in the on press I can just pass
in an empty function we look into that a
bit later here now we want an icon so to
get the icon you can go to this website
I'll mention the link in the description
below this is my GitHub repository where
you can find all the source codes for
what we are doing it today so to get
this well we need the docslogo.png as
well and the g logo which is Google logo
we want both of them so let's install
them right away having installed both of
them here we will create an assets
folder this assets folder is going to
contain all of our assets if you want
you can change the font style so you can
bring in that here as well now in that
assets I'm going to have images and in
those images we are going to put in our
two images which is this
I'll just drag them in the images folder
and here we have it cool now we will go
to the pub specific.yaml file so that we
register the images that we have in our
application
so let's just uncomment these three
lines and your pass in assets slash
images and then pass in docs Dash logo
dot PNG
similarly we are going to do it for G
logo as well so we'll just pass in G
over
and here you can see it says G logo 2 so
we can have G logo 2 but you'll get one
because I already have that image stored
in my Apple uh in my finder
or the search Explorer
having this we can stop our app and
restart it because well we can't restart
it right now but after fixing this error
we have to restart our application
because you made changes in pub
spec.tamil file
now here in the icon we have to pass in
image dot asset and pass in the asset
name which is well assets slash Images
slash g logo dot PNG
then in the label we are going to pass
in a text
so we will have constant text saying
sign
in with Google
then I'll just put trailing commas so
that it formats the document well enough
now let's try to run our application and
see where we've got and here you can see
it's saying unable to load asset and the
reason for that is here we need to pass
in G logo 2 not g logo so I'll just save
this much and here you can see a big
button showing up now the reason this
button is so big is because this image
size is pretty big now we need to reduce
this image size so what we can do is in
the image.asset just pass in the height
as 20. after we do this much you can see
it's pretty small now after having the
appropriate height for this image we
just we still need this icon to be
bigger and it should be white in color
and the text should be black in color so
let's make those changes pretty quickly
for the style we'll just pass an
elevated button dot style from
and then we will have to pass minimum
size the minimum size is going to be
constant size
150 comma 50.
so this will represent the width and
this will represent the height
now you can see it's showing up good
enough now we just need to change this
to White so we'll just pass in the
background color and the background
color is going to be colors.y now
instead of writing all our colors like
this normally what we can do is
in the lip folder create a new file
called colors.dot and as and when we get
a new color for example colors.white or
colors.blue we can just save it in here
so how I'm going to save is constant
K white color
is equal to colors.white
also import the material package because
we are using colors
and then we can take this
past 10 year
and import the package
you can see it works well now the reason
we need to do this is because suppose we
want this docs clone to be
changing the theme for example this
needs to change the theme of the
background color here changes to Black
because
we just need to match this with the
background color so to change it we
can't obviously go around and change it
every time from here we if we have some
constants over here we can easily change
their value for example if I wanted
black from just one file I can change
the color and it changes it's pretty
cool right so we'll just save it like
them and if you want to add theme
changing options you can definitely do
it using the State Management tool you
want
great having that here you can see we
can't see a text so let's just pass in
the style which will be constant textile
and constant is not required anymore
because we are already in a constant
text here we need to pass in the color
now for the color again we'll just pass
in K black color if you're wondering why
I'm prefixing with K it's because it's a
constant it's never going to change
right so I'm just going to pass in as K
black
if you have any other better names for
example if you want to name it according
to your purpose you can do that as well
so here in the K black color I'm just
passing it in here we've already
imported it
now if we come here this looks good now
the next thing we need to look at is
Google sign in so for Google sign in we
are going to use a package called Google
sign in it's from flutter itself and
we're going to use this so now let's
quickly install that I'm going to use
the dot add dependency thing here and
just pass in Google sign in after
flutter Pub get is done we can just go
to the pubspect.aml file just to see if
it's there and it's there great now we
can close this file we can close this
terminal as well and then close all the
save files now we need to do the sum
installation process for Google sign in
since you're not using Firebase for this
we have to do some extra stuff for
example we need to register our
application to Google Cloud platform so
now we'll just click over here and go
there after you come to this screen just
click over here and then click on new
project
here we will be asked to mention a
project name I'll just name it Docs
clone tutorial because I already have
the Google Docs clone project name
created I'll click on create
and after this is done I'll see you
after this process is done you can just
click on select project now after coming
in here you need to go to the
credentials
then your click on create credentials
and then we need to create oauth client
ID just click over here and you can see
to create an oath client ID we must
first configure the constraint screen so
we need to configure the consent screen
after this now just see what you're
doing I'm just going to keep it external
and then click on create then we need to
mention app name and stuff so let's
quickly type all of that
civil app docs clone tutorial then the
email I'm just going to keep in this
then I'm going to skip all of this this
is not necessary and again here I need
to mention my email address and then
click on Save and continue
after that we need to manage the scope
let's click on scope and what all
information do we need well first we
need the email that's very important
then we need
foreign
as well and that's pretty much all we
need so we can just click on update
after scrolling down and here you can
see we have all of it now click on Save
and continue
then if you want you can add the test
users because you're doing external
so basically until you have it until you
have the
app registered with Google you can use
these test users
and you can only have a hundred of them
but after that you can submit your app
for review to Google Docs or Google
cloud and all of that will be done now
I'll just click on ADD users and add my
emails I added some of my emails and
after which I just click on saved and
continue make sure these emails are the
ones you're using Google sign in with so
basically whenever that Google sign in
pop-up box appears you want to select
the email right so just pass in the
email that you want or that you will be
selecting and you can add as many as you
want till 100 so that's great
now we can come back to the dashboard
and if you want you can just click here
to publish your app but I don't want to
do that I just want to keep it for
testing so I'm not going to go there now
again we can go to our credentials click
on create credentials and then oauth
client ID now what is our application
type well we have to do it for web
Android and iOS so let's do it one by
one for everything we'll have Android
first
then in the name we'll pass in
docs Android then we need the package
name so for the packet name let's go
over here in our Android dot manifest
XML file just copy this package name and
paste it over here
then we need the finger certificate
fingerprint
try to use this if this doesn't work
just open up your terminal and copy this
line I'll mention it in the description
below just copy it and then click on
enter this will give the Sha 1 or sha256
whatever that's needed we need fha1 so
I'll copy this and paste it in here then
click on Create and we make sure to
download this Json file this client ID
is not of much use to us because we
already have Json file and similar to
Firebase we are going to set it up so
in our app in the app folder we're going
to store our Json file so let's go to a
finder click on downloads and here name
it as Google services dot Json file I've
named it as Google services 2 because
Google services already exists in my
finder I need to delete it so now having
this we have Google services created no
need to do anything or tamper with
anything wire it's not needed now just
rename this to Google services.json file
great now let's close all of this
for Android let's see what else do we
need to do
that's pretty much all that we need for
Android so now
we can go to the build.gradle
your update the flutter minimum SDK
version to 21 and here
will enable multi decks
having done all of this I don't think
anything else is needed
so we'll close this file now we need to
configure for iOS to configure for iOS
make sure that you have a Mac OS or you
have Mac OS in your application in your
system or you have virtual machine set
up so that you can work with us but if
you don't if you only have Windows and
have no virtual machines you can't build
apps for and or iOS
so just skip through this process uh the
timestamps are mentioned in the
description below we'll open it in xcode
now we can go to our Google Cloud
console again click on create
credentials oauth client ID and now we
will register IOS app now what is our
client name well iOS
docs clone
now we need the app bundle ID to get the
bundle ID we'll go to Runner we'll click
over here on the runner
copy this bundle identifier and paste it
in here then we can click on create
we need to download the placed file as
well so we'll just rename this we'll
rename this to Google service
it's not like this I guess it's Google
service info and after this hyphen
yeah that that's it but I need to put it
in desktop so that I can rename this
correctly because I already have that
created so I'll put this in runner and
then click on finish
now let's see if I name this correctly
I'll go to the iOS integration part here
you can see Google service info it's
correct we have put it in runner we've
completed all these steps now we need to
go to the info dot list file
for iOS don't go in Mac make sure to go
in iOS info dot list and in here we need
to pass in this whole bunch so we can
just copy this paste it here and here
you can see it says to pass in Reverse
client ID instead of this so how can we
do that well just go to Google service
info take this reverse client ID and go
to info.plist and paste it in here
copy the save this much
and there we have it
we have done this now we need to go to
the Pod file uncomment this line and
yeah that's pretty much it
final configuration is for web so we'll
have to create another client ID we'll
call this web
and let's call this web docs clone
now you can see authorized JavaScript
Origins this basically means what URI is
or what URLs are accepted
for that application to run on well what
will we use if you're deploying it
online you'll have to pass in the name
over here but since we're just doing it
locally as of now we can just click on
ADD URI pass in HTTP slash slash
localhost
3000
that's one that we're going to have
then we can click on download Json
again go to our downloads
and here we have this Json file
we can click on OK then we will go to
our Google sign in and see what we need
to do for web
we just need to copy this line after
copying this we'll go to index.html for
web
in the head we will pass in this line
now we need to pass in the oauth client
ID
to get the oauth client ID all we need
is this line so we'll just paste it in
here
let's remove this extra
and save it
yeah it's not necessary for you to put
it over here you can even put it over
here somewhere but it has to be in this
block which is the head block don't put
it outside of this somewhere here just
put it somewhere here inside of this
block
after this is done well that's all we
need we don't need the Json file
if you have it just delete it now if we
try to run our application uh and if we
try to use Google login on web on this
port which is just some random Port it
won't work because we've passed in the
port as localhost 3000 and it will only
work there if you deploy it online on
some website it won't work even there
because the URL over there is different
so yeah once you deploy your application
somewhere on the web you need to pass
that URL in the Google Cloud platform as
well to do that you can just click on
this edit button
and pass in the URI again it's that
simple
again it's in credentials and here you
can pass it in and if you're working on
Android and iOS apps they don't accept
com.example apps the package that we
have for example if I go to the Android
got manifest you can see the package
name here is this they won't accept apps
with com.example you have to name it
something else so obviously there are
packages that will help you
change the package name throughout the
application and then you can deploy it
on the Play store but after that you
again have to register over here because
this works for com.example app not for
the newly registered
package name right now having all of
this setup let's see how we can run on
the web so if we just go to Google sign
in web package here you can see
this is how we can run on a specific
Port so if I just type it 10 over here
you can see we need to pass in flutter
dash dash Chrome
and it has to be localhost so you can
type that this is not generally required
because anyways the default one is
localhost and then you can have webport
now since we passed in 3000 I'll pass in
3000 here if you've passed in something
else as the port you need to pass that
so if I run this much it will open the
app in localhost 3000 let's wait for it
to Launch
and here yeah our application is there
now we need to configure the Google sign
in so for that we are going to create a
repository because it's going to be some
business logic and we're going to create
a file called auth underscore repository
dot dot here I'm going to create the
class auth repository and then we are
going to have well first of all instance
of Google sign in so we will have Google
sign in and we are going to make this
private
we are not going to initialize this
we're going to take it from The
Constructor so that it's easier for us
to do unit testing uh where the video on
it unit testing widget testing and
integration testing will be out very
soon so stay on a lookout for that but
for now it's just helpful in unit
testing so that we can create mocks if
you're already familiar with it you'll
know this
and we've made this private I'll tell
you why
another thing that we might need is and
other Constructors that we need we can
look after them later on but now we can
just generate Constructor for this if
you're wondering how I got this you can
just go to the extensions Tab and
download Dot
class generator package it's pretty
useful
now here you can see it's already giving
us an error because
we can't have private variables in
Constructor that doesn't really make
sense so
what I'm going to do here is remove all
the required part and just type in
Google sign in
and then have this
also make this a required field
here we need to make sure that we pass
in Google sign in as Google sign in what
we're basically doing is creating a
private variable which we will use
throughout our application but here we
are accepting Google sign in from the
Constructor since we can't have the
private variable over here we are
passing it as a public variable but the
scope of it is limited to this
Constructor because that's how they work
and then here I'm asserting that this
Google sign in is equal to Google sign
in so this private variable is equal to
whatever value is passed in over here
why are we doing this well if we just
pass in Google sign in and you required
this dot Google sign in this should work
right but what's the point of this when
Google sign in
is a public variable that means it can
be easily accessed the point of making
this private is that the scope of it is
limited to this class only we don't want
other classes to access this Google sign
that's why we are doing this
if we just make it a public variable
like this it will
allow us to use this instance of the
class
but that's not what we want so this is
how we're going to do now
having this now we will create the
function called void sign in with Google
and we're going to pass in asynchronous
again a try and a catch block
and in case of any errors let's just
print out
a we will obviously replace this print
because they are not available in
production code but we will replace this
later on when we do the error handling
part for now we just using the Google
sign-in plugin so what we're going to do
is very very simple we're just going to
have
Google sign in DOT sign in
and that will allow us to do the Google
sign in part that's how easy it is now
if we just hover over this you can see
it will return to us a future of Google
sign in account so we can just have
final user is equal to Google sign in
and we will await this now we will also
check if user is not equal to null
then we can do other tasks for now we
can just print out let's say users
email
and users
display name
if you want you can also print out the
user's profile picture
but all of that is not really needed in
our application we will be storing all
of this data in our state management
tool but all of this is very unnecessary
I'm just storing it because if you want
to use this application later on in some
other
Parts you can have this source code
ready and expand on it because then
you'll need email and all of that stuff
now I'll just try to refresh it
then oh and before doing this we also
need to create provider
Now to create a provider well obviously
we will use riverpod
so what we are going to do here is pass
the instance of this class to this
provider so we're going to call this
auth repository provider
and here we're going to have provider
we'll get a ref here this ref is of the
type provider ref if I just show it to
you this provider ref is basically a
thing an object that will allow us to
interact with other providers right now
it's not necessary so we can just pass
an underscore but when one of your
provider suppose this provider depends
on another provider this ref will be
very useful for us
and here I just need to pass in auth
repository here you can see it asks for
Google sign in so we can just pass an
instance of Google sign in class
that's all that we need
why are we creating this provider well
obviously instead of doing auth
repository passing in Google sign in and
creating instance of Google sign and
class continuously what we can do is use
this provider this will allow us to
use auth use this class very easily and
it will allow us to test our
applications better as well
so this is the best choice in my opinion
now we can go to the login screen again
here instead of having a stateless
widget we are going to have a consumer
widget what is this consumer widget here
you can see after converting it to
Consumer widget which is given by
flutter riverpod package
we get something known as widget ref
this widget ref is like provider ref but
provider ref allows us to interact with
providers widget ref will allow us to
interact with widgets right pretty
simple
so after extending this we can have
widget ref why do we need widget ref
well you can see its provider we can't
directly use auth repository provider
anywhere right to call this auth
repository provider Vu we need ref
so we can use ref and then use read like
provider package
we can use ref dot read but since we are
in the build method we'll use ref.watch
and then we'll have auth repository
provider
and then we need sign in with Google
and that's our application and that's
the line that we need instance of
instead of creating instance of uh auth
repository class all we did was this
line and this will help us when our app
gets bigger so now you won't understand
the difference you'll think creating
instance of a class is very much easier
but trust me this one is much much
better
now I'll just create a function for this
called sign in with Google
taken a widget ref from the argument
and then call this method ref dot watch
auth repository provider DOT sign in
with Google now since we are outside the
build function we can use ref.read
now we can use sign in with Google
function
and pass it in like this
also remove this n from here
and then we need to pass in the widget
ref save this much and we have the app
ready also if you go to your
pubspect.aml file you can see flutter
riverpod version is 1.0.4 which matches
the latest version but
in mid-september flutter River Port 2.0
is going to be released and it's pretty
much going to be similar with the
pre-release version so I'm going to use
this as of now there won't be any
difference I'm pretty sure about that
so I'm just going to replace this with
this version if you have 2.0.0 make sure
to use that it's always great to stay on
the stable version but with riverpod
packages I'm pretty sure pre-release
versions are safe as well I've never
encountered anything that would change
my application
so your address we are using 2.0
with the pre-release version again I'll
repeat
if you have 2.0 release already please
check it and make this 2.0 but
for me it's not available yet so I'm
going to use the pre-release version
there won't be any differences so don't
worry about it whatever we are going to
use is pretty basic stuff of forever pod
so
it won't get changed anytime soon
now we can exit our application run our
application again and let's wait for it
to launch and see if it's working so our
app has launched and as you can see
which localhost 3000 I'm going to click
on sign in with Google
and it's throwing me an error you can
see that
why is this error because whenever we
use flutter riverpod if you are familiar
with provider we always need to wrap it
with the storehouse widget a a provider
that will store all the information of
other providers for reverpod it's pretty
easy we'll just wrap it with a widget
called provider scope
and we need to import this
and make it a constant so
this provider scope will allow us to use
other providers and it will act as a
storehouse for other providers as well
and if you scroll down you can see a
widget that stores the state of
providers all flatter applications using
riverpod must contain this at the root
of The Witcher 3. this is the root of
our widget tree my app so I'm having
that let's restart the application and
then click on sign in with Google
here you can see I'm sent to another
thing I'll just pass in my email and
password I've logged in and let's see if
I'm getting anything you can see this is
my email this is my display name and
this is my avatar so if I just go over
here click on open
you can see R showing up
that's great all of these things the
Google sign-in part is now working now
the next part we need to do is we need
to store all of this in a database
correct so now we will have to create a
node server and then set up mongodb to
store all of this data in mongodb before
diving into the code of node.js let's
understand what exactly node.js is if
you go to their website it will say
node.js is a JavaScript runtime built on
Chrome's V8 JavaScript engine basically
JavaScript cannot be run
outside of the browser so node.js was
built exactly to do that it could be run
outside the browser after using this
tool that's all node.js does it allows
us to use JavaScript outside of this
browser so obviously node.js uses
JavaScript but node.js allows us to do
multiple more things it will allow us to
create our own servers it will allow us
to create apis it will allow us to
create sockets and manage them what
exactly socket will get to it when we
get to it in the tutorial but basically
it establishes bi-directional
communication if you're confused don't
worry about it we'll go through it later
but
node.js just fastens all of our
processes
riding plain JavaScript would be very
much difficult but with node.js it's
much much more easier node.js doesn't
just allow us to create servers and all
of that good stuff it also allows us to
create terminal apps for example if you
open up your terminal and want to do
something with your terminal only
node.js even allows that but we are only
going to look at creating apis sockets
and all of that stuff so what does this
line even mean JavaScript runtime built
on Chrome's V8 JavaScript engine well we
all know what a runtime is you can
consider node.js kind of like a
framework a backend framework
for example flutter is a front-end
framework node.js is a backend framework
and Chrome's V8 JavaScript engine this
line right here basically Chrome runs on
this JavaScript engine which is called
V8 and this V8 JavaScript engine is
written in C plus plus which means it's
terribly fast by terribly fast I mean
it's pretty fast not in a bad way but it
just means simply that Chrome V8 allows
us to execute JavaScript code and that's
exactly what node.js is using Chrome is
built on Chrome's V8 engine even node.js
is built on Chrome's V8 engine and thus
allows us to write code over there so
this is pretty much all about node.js I
think you got a very brief idea about it
so now if you want to install it if
you're on Windows this will show you
windows and just click on this version
or this version this version is
recommended for most users but I'm using
18 version and if you want to verify
that you've installed successfully just
go to your terminal and write node dash
dash version and it says version 18.1.0
but I don't think it will make a
difference even if you use a lower
version like 16.17 even 14 works just
well for me as so now let's get done
with all of this now we'll come to our
root file let's close all the save files
clear of a terminal and in the root we
need to create a folder so I'm going to
type make directory which is mkdir which
will make a folder and we need to name
This Server so now we have a server
folder ready instead you could just
click over here and create a folder same
thing but it should be in the root of
your uh
folder of docs clone
now let's go to the server so I'm going
to use CD which means change directory
server
and now I'm going to run npm init this
npm is node package manager node package
manager is like pub.dev so if you just
go to their website
which is npmgs.com
you can see this npm right here this is
not the real name don't get confused by
it it's just for fun if you just click
over here you can see it keeps on
changing
anyways so here you can search for
packages just like flutter we can have
multiple packages for example if in
flutter View using HTTP package you can
have the same thing here as well which
is HTTP the same thing I mean this one
is same but there are multiple that are
different as well for example if you
want to use something like Express that
was mentioned over here you can see
we're going to use this as well so
basically this will manage all the
packages and npm
will allow us to initialize our node
project so here we are just writing npm
init and then if we click on enter just
try to do it yourself you'll see that
you'll get a bunch of options you just
have to click enter on them but a
shortcut to avoid that is just typing
Dash Y which means that you'll
initialize it and all the options that
are asked later on will be defaulted to
yes that's exactly what we wanted so
I've done that npm init Dash file
now in the server folder I'm going to
create a new file called index.js in
this index.js before coming over here we
need to go to the package.json now what
exactly is package.json package.json can
be considered like pubspec.yaml file it
contains a name version description the
main file which means the file that we
want to run in the start
the scripts well multiple scripts that
we'll have we'll get into this in just a
minute then you have author license
every everything that you need
to create a flutter package
and your node package it's just the same
thing as pubspect.tml file it will
manage all our dependencies it will
manage all our Dev dependencies
similar everything is pretty similar
so now in the scripts I want to change
something so we are going to add two
scripts well first of all is the start
one which means which is short for
node dot slash index.js now what does
this mean wait a second I'll show it to
you for example here I type console.log
hello world if you're wondering what
console.log is it's basically print in
Dot
it will just print it out to the
terminal and
if you're on web it will print it out on
the web
here if I just type let's say node dot
slash
index.js because I'm in the server
folder I can use dot slash if I was in
the root folder I would have to use dot
slash server slash index.js it's
relative routing
now if I just click on enter you can see
Hello World prints out
what I've done here is instead of
writing this command this entire big
command what I can do is just use npm
start
and it does the same thing it will run
this command when uh behind the scenes
and print the same thing out to us
why is this needed well
if you deploy deploy it online you will
have to use something like npm start so
that it starts a server you can't use
nodes dot slash index.js and now let's
try to install some dependencies to
install our dependencies what do we use
to do well we would use this dot add
dependency otherwise we would go to
pubspect.aml file and over here manually
add them but
another the third option would be to use
something like flutter Pub add and then
the name of the dependency right that's
exactly what we're going to do over here
here we are going to write npm
I or install both of them work even
iWorks even install Works other name
suggests it will install dependencies
whatever we type here so what all
dependencies do we need well I said we
need Express right we'll install that
I'll tell you what Express means when we
get it then we need HTTP I said we're
going to need that you'll understand
when we write the code
then we need socket dot IO at 2.3.0 this
is very important
socket.io at 2.3.0 why do we need at
2.3.0 well because the sockets are
managed in such way that it needs to be
connected on the client side as well and
in the server side as well so when we
are connecting it on the client side
we're going to use another package
because we can't manually write the
whole socket client code it's very big
and it's very tough to understand as
well so we already have a package for it
that's it exactly what we're going to
use and that package that we're going to
use socket IO client
has to have a socket IO version of 2.3.0
then only it will work it won't work
without that
so we need to make sure that we add this
version
if we add like this it will install the
latest version but if we write at
2.3.0 it will install this specific
version and then it won't give us any
errors later on when we connect to the
client side when we get to the socket
part you'll understand it better when we
read the documentation as well another
thing that we need is Json web token
Json web token short for JWT
will allow us to securely store our
token or create a token
based on the user ID and this token will
be stored on our device and that will
allow us to purchase the state in our
application that's why we need this and
finally we need Mongoose what is
Mongoose well
it's just a data object model for
mongodb using Mongoose all the mongodb
tasks get quite simpler like connection
sending data to the server and it gets
more organized in my opinion so I'm
going to use this mongoose
after that we are just going to click on
enter and you can see all of them got
installed and we have a new folder of
node modules this node modules contains
all the necessary files that we have and
it's pretty big
so you can ignore it and if you're
uploading it to GitHub this project you
need to make sure that you have dot get
ignore file here and pass in node
underscore modules like this if you're
not using GitHub don't worry about this
so now that we know about console.log
let's remove it now let's import all the
packages that we have
added right so
in flutter we used to do import and then
pass in the name like this package
HTTP from
HTTP dot dot this is how we used to
import stuff here it's a bit different
we need to do constant Express is equal
to require Express
with this we have imported it this
Express we have imported it and stored
it in a variable you can understand what
this means even in flutter we have the
variable expression constant Express
equal to require Express this means
Express cannot be re-initialized or re
given a value again
after that we'll import mongoose
let's require Mongoose as well
then let's have constant app equal to
express
what we have done here is basically
initialized Express and stored it in the
app variable so we have imported Express
and here we are just initializing
Express just like we do we call the
function right that's exactly what we
have done and stored it in this app
variable
then we need to
do app Dot listen now what is this
listen method well listen method is
basically helping us to start our server
so when we use this it will continuously
listen to our server and will respond
so here first of all in the lesson
method we need to supply it with a port
so on which Port should it start running
you can see our web is running our web
was running on the version 3000 but
even this has to run somewhere right so
exactly we need to pass in a port now we
are going to store it over here which is
called constant Port let's store it over
here so that All Imports stay on the
same line all initializations on the
same line and app Dot listen at the end
of the file it's not necessary to make
stay make it stay at the end of the file
but if you put it at the end it seems
much more organized right
so we can say the port as 3000 again but
our server is already our web is already
running on Port 3000 so let's have it on
3001. right
or
if that's not there this is a shorthand
so if the port 3001 is not there and it
will always be there so
so the port here is going to be process
dot EnV dot port if you're if you have
developed many apps you might know that
you have you have to store some secret
information inside of dot EnV file so
that they stay secure and are not
visible to the public but this is
exactly what we're going to do
process.env.port
otherwise if that's not present this is
3001 not thirty thousand one three
thousand one so basically this
process.env.org is stored in the site to
which we deploy for example if you're
deploying on Heroku or Firebase This
Server then we need to make sure that we
provide it with a port it can't run on
3001. it's only for local development
but on the web it will already give us
with the EnV port and we will access
this using
process.env.port but what if we are
doing local development we don't have
process.env.port in that case
we want to use 3001 this is exactly what
we are doing if process.tnv.port is
present which is usually present in the
size to which we deploy our server to if
that's not present then we will use 3001
and it's most likely the case that
we are doing local development in our
case it will show up 3001. look so if
here I pass in the port because first a
port is needed and then a callback
function
but before that I'm going to pass in
0.0.0.0 which basically means that you
can access this from anywhere from any
IP address that you want you can access
This Server so I've passed in 0.0.0 then
we need a callback function so whenever
the app is connected what do we say so
we'll just pass in
console.log
connected
at Port
dollar
port
and we can't put in
Port so we are going to have Port 3000
one now let's just save it and run npm
start again
if I just do this you can see connected
at Port 3001 let me collect the spelling
and here we have it now this is the way
we create functions in JavaScript you
pass into pattern to parenthesis then
Arrow function then a block
and then whatever you want to pass in
alternatively what you can do is just
write in function here and it will solve
the error if you just try to run it
again you'll have to close this because
it hasn't noticed the changes whenever
we make a change we need to restart the
server so to exit it we can just type
Ctrl C and it will exit it then we will
write pass in npm start again and you
can see it again connects to the port
3000 one
both the syntax are fine I just like
this one better because it's shorter and
less use of keywords right
I'll again stop this and start it you
can see it still works it's absolutely
fine
now
if you want
to use something like this you know in
our
flutter we used to do if we wanted to
paste some variable here we would have a
string and then over here we need to
pass in the variable but here you can
see there is no highlighting and if I
save the file start my server again you
can see it says connected our code Port
it hasn't noticed the string
interpolation that's what it's called
and flutter when we used to do this it
used to work for example if I just go in
the main.dart file
here I want to pass in the key color for
example let's say k black color
I used to do this and the highlighting
used to come and now the name is flutter
demo and then colors.white
colors are black sorry
but that didn't happen here why because
here you need to provide back text
instead of normal string so when you do
this it will identify this as a variable
this backtick is present below the
Escape key
now if you try to start it you can see
connected
at portport and it's still showing that
because I haven't saved the file when I
save the file and try to do it again you
can see connected at Port 3001 great now
you've noticed we have created a server
that's how simple it was just these many
lines of code and we have created a
server let me remove this comment I hope
you've understood everything till now
now the next part is you notice that
we've written so many npm starts here
that's not very ideal you know making
some change and then restarting the
server again doing so much tasks
sometimes we just forget and it will
cause us to scratch our heads and think
what we've done wrong but nothing really
was wrong except starting the server so
how do you fix that well for that we
need to install a Dev dependency which
is called nodemon
so when we install it like this it will
save it in dependencies but we want it
as a Dev dependency because it's only a
developer dependency we don't want it in
our application we just want it for our
own use so we're going to use it as a
Dev dependency how do we install it dash
dash save Dev
so you've installed nodemon this will
install it in dependencies but to make
it
save in Dev dependencies you'll have to
use dash dash save Dev when you click on
enter you can see it is loading
if it's installed let me clear the
terminal as well and if you come over
here Dev dependencies now has no remote
aware node mon will allow us to start a
server very quickly so once I start node
ball
it will keep running a server and
whenever we make a change and save our
file it will again restart the whole
server we don't have to do it by
ourselves now of course we need a script
for that as well otherwise we'll have to
keep writing no demon dot slash index.js
so here what I'm going to do is create
another script called Dev and then write
nodemon dot slash index.js
and put in a comma
then we'll come to index.js file
let's try to run it again but now we'll
run npm run Dev with npm start this used
to get executed with npm run Dev this is
going to get executed
so now I'll just click on enter and you
can see connected at Port 3001.
now if I just type in console.log
hey this is changing
and if I click on save you can see it
restarted the server then it has
connected airport 3001 and hey this is
changing my spelling is wrong but
anyways
so you can see it's automatically
restarting our whole server now we have
a proper base to start from now the next
step is to connect our database to our
application
so this is how Mongoose is going to help
us but before connecting it to Mongoose
we need the database setup so let's get
to it so to create mongodb or setup
mongodb we need to go to this website
mongodb.com then click on the sign
option and then use your desired option
to sign up so let's just click over here
and then use whatever you want I've
already created an account so I'm just
going to use that and I'll see you after
I log in so I've come to this screen you
might not see the screen in the start
you'll have to fill in some information
if you're signing up for the first time
but since I'm already logged in I'm not
seeing the start startup screen just
fill in all the information that you'll
require after sign up and then you'll
ultimately come to a screen that looks
like this you just need to click here
then click on new project then you have
to mention the project name I'm just
going to call this docs clone tutorial
and then click on next then you can add
any members that you want I don't have
any so I'm just going to click on create
project here it asks us to build a
database first so we will click over
here
then we are going to use the free
cluster there's dedicated one and the
serverless as one you can read all the
information that's required and that
will help you I'm going to go with the
free option
then here I'll just select all the
default options and then click on create
cluster then it asks us for the username
and password and make sure that whatever
you type in your is correct and you have
it secured
and you remember it because this will be
needed and the next step that we will
use when we need to connect to our
database from our code right here
so I'm just going to enter some username
and some password after you pass in it
just click on create user and this will
have it you have this if you want other
username and password to use it you can
use that as well but for me one is
enough if you have more team members
make sure to use that it will be very
easy for you to segregate and see what
who did what and later on
anyways so where we what we like to
connect from the cloud environment or
from the local environment I'm going to
use the local environment so I'm just
going to pass in
0.0.0.0 that means that your IP address
is available to anyone and it can be
used anywhere as I mentioned over here
as well
0.0.0.0 basically means that it can be
accessed from anywhere if you want to
add any description add that otherwise
just click on ADD entry then we can
click on finish and close and go to our
database while our database is being
deployed let's write some code to
connect it it's pretty simple as I've
already mentioned we are going to use
Mongoose for it it makes our connection
stuff very easy and it will later on
also provide us with some modeling which
will make our code cleaner and even
easier to connect and save update or
delete data from mongodb
so here I'm just going to connect it so
for connecting it's as simple as it gets
it's just we have to use this Mongoose
and call Dot connect with this we have
the connected ready if you hover over
this and in here you need to pass in the
URL so here I'm just going to pass in
constant DB and this DB link will be
whatever we get from here whenever this
database gets deployed we will have to
click on this connect button which will
give us the URL so if yours is already
there you can try it out but I'm just
going to pass in like this
and whenever I get the database link I
can just pass it in over here but now
only doing this much isn't enough
because connect is a promise what is a
promise you can consider it like a
future like in dot we have future so to
use a future if we are in a function we
can make that function async and then
use await and then we can resolve that
future
or if you are outside of a function and
you don't have any function then you can
use dot then function right and that
will give you a function for example or
some data so you'll get some data here
and then you can use that data to
suppose print that data
that's how Dart works and similar to
that JavaScript works as well you have
the dot then method and Dot catch method
similar to dot so we can just have dot
then
and whenever this kind of thing happens
we will just say console.log
connection successful
otherwise there is an error right so we
can just catch that error
and then just print it out so we'll
write console.log error
save this much and our connection should
be successful now if I just open up my
terminal you can see invalid scheme
because the database URL is incorrect
now let's try to see our database has
been deployed if it's taking more time
try to refresh it and see even after
that if it's not happening then wait for
some more time if it happens then you
can just click on this connect button
then click on connect your application
with mongodb Native driver via the
driver as node.js and we have the
version 18. if you have 16 it still
works you can see we need 4.1 or higher
now we can just copy this mongodb URL
paste it in here and now you can see we
have our username that we typed in
earlier now we need to pass in password
so let's just remove this make sure to
include these angle brackets if they are
there it will cause an error and you
will not be able to connect so just
remove them and pass in your password my
password is pretty simple I'm going to
change it later on as a matter of fact
I'm going to delete this database after
my project is completed
so don't try to copy this URL create
your own so you'll even be able to see
the data and you can see connection is
successful now if I just try to let's
say change this you can see it's giving
me an error that means it's working
successfully
if you want to see the data how can you
see it well first of all close this go
to this cluster and then in the
collections tab
you'll be able to see everything but
since you have not created any data you
can't see anything so now let's try to
save save our data what is the data that
we're going to save the user data so
whenever your the user registers
we just know we just pop up a Google
sign in button and whenever the user
clicks on that Google sign in button
the user gets logged in from the from
the account they selected from the
pop-up but how do we know that the user
has logged in into our application we
have no idea currently because
Google sign-in doesn't store it to any
console any database nothing it just
tells us and gives us data
so now we need to make sure that we
store it in a database and exactly for
that we are going to use mongodb so how
are we going to do it well as I
mentioned we are going to use Mongoose
for that and store the data but before
that we have to create a rest API what
is the rest API the full form for it is
representational State transfer
basically whenever you request to a
server
some data
you can only do it using an API correct
so we are going to make that API which
is application programming interface you
might have used somewhere in your
application for example when you're
using HTTP calls if you made some
application so you're requesting or
getting some data using http.get that's
exactly basically what we're going to
get so whenever we request some server
some data using suppose HTTP get or post
whatever request you sent in
it will send back to you the current
state of the database that's exactly and
simply what we're going to do and that's
basically what rest even means
so how are we going to do that well we
have to create API for that we can
create that using node that's why we
have used node but with Express this
plugin that we have installed or package
you can call it this package allows us
to make our rest apis even quicker than
expected so let's try to use this
Express and create our application so
what I'm going to do is
here I'm going to pass in
Express not express because we have not
initialized it using App we can call so
we can use app.get or app.post
and then Define an API and we are going
to call this slash API slash sign up
this is the route of our API basically
if you if your server right now is
running on localhost
3001 right
now
if I just pass in slash API slash sign
up it will
and use a post request for that
it will make sure that it runs whatever
code we call inside the Callback
function which is this function and this
function let me create that function
will have something known as request and
response with request
you can access many multiple headers for
example you can access header body
whatever data
you want to send in from the client side
can be accessed using request and
whatever data you want to send can be
used using risks or response you can
name this anything you want these are
basically variables to access those
uh the objects that are sent to us so
that we can
make sure that our API works
so with request we are able to get the
information from the client side with
the response we'll be able to send some
data but we look into it but now another
problem comes in I just have this slash
API slash sign up what if my user also
wants to suppose
get the data
so I'll have to create another API for
it called app dot API get let's say
let's call this slash API slash get and
this will be a get request there are
many types of requests get post delete
update patch
you can use all of them and these are
the most frequently used ones we are
mainly going to use both of them in our
application today for the delete one
you'll have enough idea to
make sure you can delete anything but
we're just going to use get and post so
I have get here and post here that's how
we are going to work but what if I have
more uh apis created for example I want
something known as
update user information I even want to
delete the user account so will I keep
creating your
but
I can keep creating here but that would
just make my code very messy what if my
application doesn't have login for
example in our application you also want
to create the documents you also want to
save the documents we also want to
update the title of our document how are
we going to do all of that in just a
single file of course we can but imagine
this for a very big app for the real
Google Docs if they use such kind of
structure it will just make their app
such pathetic right so we are going to
make sure that we shift our code into a
separate file of its own so that it's
clearly distinguishable if you want to
do user tasks you can do it in one
separate file if you want to do document
task you can do it there correct so
let's remove all of this from here
save it and then we can go to the server
file create a new folder called routes
and in this routes I'm going to create
user.js file
so this is the route we are going to
create all the user related routes in
this file itself
now I'm going to
require Express again because this file
doesn't have any
import lines
just because this has doesn't mean even
this file has access to this
correct
just like after other file if you have
an import line here doesn't mean a login
screen also has that import line there
are two separate files so we'll import
that now we can of course initialize app
and have constant app equal to express
but instead of doing this there's
another method you can take and I find
this much much more cleaner
which is using constant
auth router
which will be equal to Express dot
router
so with this I have auth router created
now I can use authorotter dot post
slash API slash sign up
then I can have request response again
it's the exact same thing just we have
created this auth x router using this
router method
and we have created it in a separate
file that's all
now of course our tasks are going to be
asynchronous because you're going to use
mongodb it's an external service and we
have to store data on the web whenever
we have to do such kind of stuff we
always require the methods to be
asynchronous so I'm going to pass async
over here
I can't keep using dot then that's why
async away it was made that's why I'm
not using uh dot then method but of
course you can use it I just don't like
nesting very much
then I can have a try catch block
similar to Dart Whenever there you think
there can be a scope of error you can
just have a try catch block
then you need
some data for example
what do you want to store in mongodb
well it's a username the email the
profile picture that's exactly what we
had even printed in the auth repository
right all of these things we want to
save in our database so we need to get
them how are we going to get them well I
already told we are going to get them
from request.body right so with request
we are able to access
whatever client-side information is
being received and then with body we are
able to use whatever is passed through
the body
there's headers as well
but with the headers it's usually for
the auth token when we get to it I'll
let you know what this auth token is
but basically you can even access
headers and these two are the things you
are going to access in our application
today but you can access much more
information from there if you want to
know more just research about it on
Google just write request or node.js uh
Express and you'll get your specific
information
if you want to follow along well then
let's just go ahead
now I'm going to destructure it so what
is happening well in the request.body
whenever we go to the client side what
we're going to do is whenever we send a
post request what are we going to do
HTTP dot post then pass in this URL
which is localhost
3000 slash API slash sign up
then we have to pass in body
and this body is going to be an object
what is an object well basically a map
so here we are going to pass in like
this name ignore the error for now name
and then you'll pass a name then email
email
and profile picture same thing so that's
how we are going to do so now instead of
getting some object over here this will
be an object or a map so instead of
getting a map over here I'm directly
converting it to uh a string variable or
a variable it's not necessarily a string
variable JavaScript doesn't care about
that it doesn't care about the types so
here I'm going to have name email and
profile picture
and then just save it you can see we
have all three stuff
now I have access to all of this now I
have to store that data to store the
data as I said we are going to use
Mongoose but instead of directly storing
the data using [ __ ] so let's create a
model for it so models can be considered
like structures if you uh have created
an application with me before using
Firebase you already know that we create
models in in JavaScript we create mode
in Dart sorry we create models using
class this is user model we are going to
create right now as well and then we are
going to have final string email final
string
uh let's say name all of this we are
going to write later on
similar thing we are going to do in uh
JavaScript as well but using Mongoose
because in Mongoose our stuff becomes
much more easier to store of course we
can create classes in JavaScript as well
but using Mongoose it will be a much
more easier task so here I'm going to
create user.js again
since we are in models user.js I can
create it again because they both have
different routes if you want to create
user.js again in the routes folder you
won't be able to do that's pretty basic
so now in the models we are going to
first of all import Mongoose so let's
require mongoose
then here we are going to create
something known as user schema user
schema is basically the structure of our
user so house are going a user going to
be structured out is it going to have a
name email profile picture all of that's
good stuff so it's just going to have
the structure the schema that's what it
is
and how do we create it using Mongoose
we just call Mongoose dot schema
easy enough
and now we just have to pass in an
object like this so that we can provide
it with a bunch of properties so the
first property is name
let's pass in like this this is the
syntax that we're going to use whatever
property name the user will have for
example the user is going to have a name
so we pass in a name then another object
and here you pass in another properties
for example what is the type of this
name going to be
having a type is always good especially
when we have from dot it's very much
needed for us
then we are going to make sure that
required is true for example when we use
our Constructors we want it to be
required if there is no require it will
throw us an error but in that it will
throw a compile time error which means
it will literally show you in your code
that please enter your name but in
Mongoose it will show us an error over
here which is runtime error whenever we
run and start to store the data and if
it's not there then it will throw us an
error
now the next thing we require is email
similar to this it's going to have two
properties type string and required true
and then we need a profile picture
this is also going to be the same thing
Drive string required true
there are a bunch of other properties
that you can use check it out on net you
can have trim set to true
that means that the user will uh have
their string trimmed from the end that's
exactly what trim does just calling the
trim method basically
so you can add that but I don't think
any of this needs it because we are
getting it from Google directly Google
has done all of this so why do should I
do it again
right but if you don't want to take any
chances don't take just type it in
then now we have created this structure
of our application or the user but what
about the model we also want the user to
have something uh
so that they can store we we have just
defined how it should look like we have
not told it
where it should be stored how it should
be stored what should the name of the
collection be you can see our
collections what should the name of this
collection be
so for exactly that we are going to have
constant user equal to Mongoose dot
model
with this we have created a model first
we need to pass in the name of the model
which is user and then pass in the
schema which is user schema
and then we can save this much
so with this our model is completed we
have told how this should look like and
we have created a model so that we can
easily use them
now let's go to the user.js route
and actually instead of calling this
user.js let's call it auth.js it's going
to consist of all the routes using auth
not user because you're going to ask
State persistence route something like
that and
it's it comes under authentication not
really user right but this can be called
user model because it just consists data
of the user
now here
I want to find a user with the
so how are you going to proceed with
this part so how are you going to
proceed with this part well first of all
whenever we are signing up the user we
need to make sure that the same email
already exists or not so if the same
email already exists then we want to
make sure that we don't store the data
right I mean
if the email already exists we don't
want to store that data it's already
stored on the mongodb why should I waste
one call of mine which is very precious
always make sure to reduce the calls to
the database so I'll always make sure
that email already exists or not if it
does not exist
then we want to store the data but if
it's already stored then well nothing
else
correct so these are the two tasks
there's a third task as well which is
tokens we have to send we have to make
and send one but we look into it when we
get to the state persistence part which
is right after this after we connect to
this part we can go to the state
persistence part so here how do we check
if the email already exists in our
database for that we need to you know
how to call Mongoose and how to check
for the database so we are going to use
user for that but you can see I don't
get any auto option to get the user we
have created it here why am I not able
to access this user over here well
that's because the scope of this user
variable is only limited to this file
which means you can use this user
variable anywhere in this file but you
cannot use outside of this how am I
going to use this outside then well you
can just call module dot exports is
equal to user you can consider this user
to be variable to be a private variable
now and when you use this line it
becomes a public variable
now you can come to auth.js and here you
have user now I get the autocorrect
option and it requires this this is
relative routing when you use express
directly it will require the package
from node modules folder but when you
use user like this it will look for some
file
so that's the basic difference you can
also store you can also call your files
like this in flutter
that's a feature but no one really uses
it
you can use it
anyways so here how do we find the user
with the same email so well we are just
going to call user and you can see a
bunch of options already there since I
have created this user as a mongoose
model I have a bunch of options you can
see find find one find by ID remove
where add listener aggregate apply and
so on but what do I want to do well I
want to find the email do I have a find
email option no obviously why because
user
have the email property that we created
it's not necessary that if you create
another application it will have user
email
necessarily it won't have but we do have
find by ID correct that's because
the ID property is automatically
generated by mongodb itself
just like Firebase if we don't provide
ID it will automatically generate that
ID but for email that's not the case
because every user every collection for
example if I have a document collection
it won't have an email so what's the
point of having a find by email option
right so here you're going to have find
but now again the question remains how
are we going to find the user with email
then we are just going to call find one
why am I using find one and not find
because find will return to me a list of
users with the same email I'm pretty
sure that my app is only going to have
one user with the same email but even if
there are many many I just want to catch
the first one
after I get the first one
that means that the user with the CME
will already exist directly without
sending any information
or creating the new information we are
going to send the data so here
I want to find one and here again you
can see I've passed in a map or an
object because I can't just type in
email right user dot find one email that
doesn't really make sense user dot find
one email but what what email do we need
to find out
so here I'm going to make it
like this an object and then we can pass
an email this basically means user in
the user collection find one user with
this email property which matches our
email so if you want not get confused
I'll just type in email over here
so you want to find one user with the
email property as the email that we got
from our client try to
understand the sentence we want to find
one user with the email property with
the
and it should be similar to the email
that we are getting from the client side
so now I'll just remove this because
even naming this carries a big value
you'll realize later on because when we
send data from the client side we are
going to send it with the name of email
and when we are destructuring it this is
called restructuring whenever we are
destructuring it name matters very much
so I have that now I find the user now
I'll just save it to the user variable
and we are using let here let is
basically equal to variable user even
you can even have variable user
or a constant user but we won't use
constant why because we are going to
assign this user variable with something
later on
so I'm just going to have let let user
is equal to user dot find one but
this will be a promise or a future
so how are we going to resolve this well
we have a async function we can just
call await and this will store the
correct user information if it's there
so we have already now we need to make
check or if the email already exists or
not so we are going to have if the user
does not exist the syntax is allowed in
JavaScript we don't have to do if user
is not equal to null what you can do
instead if if there is no user
then we want to create a new user
correct so we can have user is equal to
new user just like you create an object
you're going to do that
and here you're again going to pass in a
map
because you can consider to remember it
you can just consider it that we've
passed in an object these are required
properties whenever we have required
properties even in flutter how do we do
it well we have to pass in all the stuff
so we are going to have email as email
we need to pass in the email correct and
this name should be equal and the same
as the name that you'll type in here so
if I pass in profile pic I'll paste this
and I want this same name to be there
and the name name will also be like this
and with this we have created a new user
and set it to this but with this much
only we have not saved anything to our
mongodb well where's the save call
correct we have just created that model
and assigned it to a variable that
doesn't mean mongodb will automatically
store it to web so to save it we are
going to use user is equal to await user
which is the small variable dot save
what have I done here well just consider
this line where you save and we have
awaited it because this is a mongodb
call it will take time
so we will have a weight user dot save
and assign this to a user variable why
are we assigning it again because as I
said mongodb will automatically create
that token ID or the ID for us not the
token sorry it will only create the ID
for us
so when it's creating that ID we also
want that user ID to be there so that we
can access in our application later on
IDs are very crucial correct
so here we are going to have user.save
and save it to this variable but if
there is no user if there is the user
already existing then we want to do
nothing basically now we have stored the
data as well now we just want to return
that data to our client side we do that
using response.json it told you response
will allow us to send data to send data
you can also use send and then send it
but with Json it will automatically
encode it in a Json formatting that will
be easier for us
and then we'll just pass in the user
and we'll pass in like this so we want
user user
alternatively what you can do
is just pass an user so when the key and
the value name are the same thing
you can use this shorter hand syntax
instead of typing this full you can just
type user and it will know that it means
user user correct
and we can do the same thing over here
as well so instead of having name name
name name you can just have name profile
pack email this will only be allowed in
objects or Maps you can't use it
anywhere else obviously you can just use
it within these curly brackets
so even here I can use it because there
is a curly bracket it's an object great
now I can send the data so let's try to
test this API now how I'm going to test
this API I don't want to go to the
client side write the whole bunch of
code and then realize I've done
something wrong I can't use this right
so to test this you can install an
extension called ThunderClan with
thunderclient you can test your apis
within your application or within your
vs code itself if you're using Android
studio to follow this tutorial
I'll recommend you to install a tool
known as Postman
Postman
will allow you to test this API and it
has much more features than
thunderclient as a matter of fact if
you're using vs code as well but if you
want more features than this Thundercat
gives you you can use Postman this will
allow you to test debug you can see
it will allow you to do that and over 20
million developers already use it
but I'm going to use this ThunderClan
because my tasks are very simple I just
want to send a post get or some kind of
a request and then I'll get some data
from here
so now what I'm going to do is touch
this API so I'll go to the
Thunder client I'll create a post
request and click on send but you can
see I cannot post slash API slash sign
up so how I'm going to do that well why
is this even happening
so this is happening because in auth.js
file we have created our auth router run
stuff that's all cool but our index.js
is the main file and it doesn't really
know what auth router is you can create
as many files as you want but you need
to register it with the main file and
the main file is what we have passed in
over here the main file index.js you
have to make sure that even index.js
knows about it because JavaScript or
node.js will only execute this code we
want for the code to be executed as well
so let our index.js file know about this
how are we going to make them know well
we're just going to use app.use this is
known as a middleware basically when the
data comes from the client side to the
server side there is something known as
middleware in between of them what does
this mean let me show you a diagrammatic
representation this is our server or the
client side this is our server site we
are sending some data from here and when
we send some data and we want some data
it will send us back over here let me
just label this this is client this is
server
sorry for my terrible drawing so
here we have the client and the server
but what if I want to manipulate some
data in between how I'm going to do that
well I can do it in the server side but
sometimes it's not just acceptable so
you do that in this middleware box this
is the middleware box I'm just going to
create it again
so with this middleware box let me just
type in m
with this middleware box I'm going to
manipulate any data coming but here I'm
not really manipulating data I'm just
using app.use
so that
I can make sure to use this auth router
so I'm just going to pass in author
outer over here
but this is called a middleware
similarly we are going to use middleware
for authentication purposes as well when
we get to it make sure to remember this
diagram if you want take a screenshot of
it a very systematic representation but
this middleware is very important for us
but you can see when we type author
outer we are not able to import it again
we have to pass in the module.exports
line so vlab module dot exports equal to
auth router
now we can take this auth router and now
we can import it as well
so
now if I try to run my application Let's
see we have no errors I'll go to the
extensions tab
use thunderclient and after you install
it you'll get this option just I'm going
to click over here I've passed in some
data already but
if you want to test your RS you can just
click on new request and pass in data
when you click on new request you'll
have to pass in this URL over your
localhost 3001 which is the port we are
on
and then slash API slash sign up
whatever route you want to test and then
you might be over here you have to go to
this body pass in a Json content like
this you have to pass in a curly bracket
then the name email and profile picture
make sure to do that single inverted
commas are not allowed only double
inverted commas are allowed
then we are going to send the data and
you can see processing is there but it's
requiring it so much time for this
processing that means something is wrong
there has to be something wrong when
there is so much wrong I mean there's so
much time and the reason for that is if
you come over here we are destructuring
this property but how are we able to
destructure it we want to make sure that
whatever data comes to us let's go to
our diagram again whatever data comes to
us from our client side to our server
side is always
in Json format we can't guarantee that
because when other developers join in it
won't be very easy for us to keep them
telling them that this has to be Json
this has to be Json right so instead of
that what we can do is app dot use
Express dot Json
so what this will do this is again a
middleware as I told you so whatever
data is coming here
it will take that it will convert it
into a Json format and send it to the
server as I said the manipulation of
data this manipulation of data has
occurred here and I said sometimes it
can't just happen in the client side
that's why now I'm going to go over here
again and now I'm going to send the
request and you can see it was very
quick it was very instant
so I've got my user already created now
if I just go to my server
and refresh it
you can see users collection is there
and here we have it this is ID this is
the automatically generated ID by
mongodb we know where mentioned it to
create it created on its own and it's of
the type object ID which is another type
created by mongodb you can consider it
this way
then we have name as Naman email as
number one to three and profile package
test one two three obviously a profile
pic is going to be different later on
but here we have it our user is now
created our models are working well now
the next part is connecting it with the
client side let's get into it so for
that I'm going to come to the auth
repository simply and where replace all
of this
with this much now let's understand what
we want to do all right so now what I'm
going to do is in the lib folder I'm
going to create a new folder called
models and in this model we are going to
create a user model file so pretty
simple it's going to be very similar to
the user model we just created it's
going to be well first of all we have to
create a class so we love class user
model
then we are going to have final string
put a file picture
final string email
final string name
but other than this we also need
something known as a token
which is going to be empty initially but
later on we are going to add this token
and another thing that we need is uid if
you're getting confused with token don't
worry I haven't explained it yet I mean
we will get to it when we get to it it's
just the next step after this sign up
process
so over here in a user model we
generated a Constructor we need other
classes as well so I'm going to generate
Json J serialization
and then just save it I'm going to close
the terminal go to this auth repository
and in here I'm going to create instance
of this user model class so I'm just
going to pass in user model then we need
to pass in the name email sorry so we
love user Dot
let's see and we have named the same
thing you can see this is user even this
is user so now we have to change this
name I'm just going to call this user
account then we will have user account
sorry this will be user dot email
this will be user dot name and this can
be null so let's pass in this over here
and this is going to be display name one
second
then we need a profile pic so we love
user.photo URL
and the uid so the uid is going to be
empty for now token is going to be empty
for now why are the empty well as I
already mentioned to you
they need to be initially empty
because we don't have the uid access yet
token access yet we all we have is these
three great after creating this we need
to send a HTTP request so to send the
HTTP request obviously we'll have the
HTTP plugin installed this is the
pub.dev page of it it's created by dot
language or Google itself
you can go through the documentation if
you don't know how to use it but I'm
going to go through in this tutorial
anyways
now for the unit testing obviously we'll
have to get the instance over here
whatever packages that are there need to
be coming from here so we are going to
have final client client and obviously
this is going to be underscore client
and we are having client because HTTP
directly provides us with post and get
methods but we don't want that we want
to use clients so that we can mock it if
you are familiar with unit testing you
might know
so I'm just going to have client client
then over here we're going to have
client set equal to the client I've
already explained this in detail now
we're gonna have client dot post I hope
that's the method if you go to our.js we
can remove this command not needed
anymore we will have post request here
so I'm just going to pass and post then
we need to pass it to a specific URL now
to get the URL what we're going to do is
create a new file in the lib folder
called constants dot dot
in this constants file we are going to
store all the constants of our
application
for now there will only be one so we'll
have constant host and then here we need
to pass in the host well of course we
have to pass in HTTP slash localhost
3001.
and why are we storing it here well if
we just come to this auth repository you
might notice that we will keep using
this host because we have to keep
sending get request or post requests
right so
we will keep using this instead of
writing this whole big string and making
some error we can just use this host and
other thing is when we deploy our
application to some server then the URL
will change it will no longer be HTTP
localhost 3001. that time
as well it will help us
so anyways your we can type in host but
another problem here is we can't have
localhost if we have localhost it won't
really work on the Android app it will
work on iOS it will work on web but it
won't work on Android so to fix this
issue we have to pass in our IP address
now to get your IP address on Mac you
can just search on the net how to get my
IP address but this IP address doesn't
have to be you know public IP address
it doesn't have to be this
public IP address
no it doesn't have to be public IP
address it has to be your own private
address just type it on the net how to
get your own private IP address if it's
public IP address it won't work if you
type on Google what's my IP address it
will just give you a public IP address
that won't be allowed you need to use a
private IP address anyways I'll just
type in my own IP address here
and see you when I get done with it all
right I'm closing my uh constraints.dart
file and in the host let's just first of
all
import it and I don't think it's
importing let's quickly import the
constants.file and here in the host we
have to pass in slash API slash sign up
whatever we named over here in our rout
router
then we need to pass in
you can see this is already giving us
error because it wants a type of URI so
we want to pass this so that it passes
this string and converts it into a URI
after that we need a callback function
not a callback function sorry we need to
pass in the body and the body is going
to be user.2 Json
not user user account dot to Json
and that's pretty much it
then we need to supply headers to it and
this header is going to be content type
application
slash Json
semicolon car set is equal to uh tutf
minus 8 or Dash 8. basically this header
will tell
this header will tell this is a type of
Json format please accept this
if it's not if you don't add this it
will give you an error or a warning
something like that then we want to save
it in a res variable we'll also call
await because this is a future and in
JavaScript terms it's uh promise now I'm
going to after getting this response I'm
just going to handle this so we are
going to have switch
res dot status code so our thing our
whole concept is determined on the fact
that what status code are we receiving
and with this I realize the error in our
code already if you see in the try block
we have sent in dot Json but here we can
also add something known as status
you can see it adds a status code this
status code can be anything for example
the most famous one is 404 404 basically
means not found that is a status code
for telling that that yeah we didn't
find this page sorry
with 200 we say that everything is okay
but we don't add it over here because by
default it is 200 if you don't mention
anything it's going to be 200.
but in the try block and in the catch
block the error that I mentioned we have
to pass in some error right so we will
just pass in dress dot Json
error
e.2 string or E Dot message whatever you
want
and here if we send it you can see again
that would be a problem because res dot
Json
will have a status code of 200 which is
not acceptable by us we want a status
code
of 500 which means internal server error
so that means that some server error has
happened we don't know what but here is
the error year is the status code
something has gone wrong it's not
successful so anything that's not 200
has to be passed in over here if you
don't pass in your error handling method
will all go wrong
all right so in our switch block we will
just write as the case let me just write
it case is 200
then what will we do
well we'll just use new user
and set it equal to user which is
this user we don't want that sorry we
want user account
so we want to use this user account and
then have useracount.copy web we don't
have the copy with function so let's go
in the user model create a copy with
function save this watch come over here
and we'll have copy with function with
this we are able to change contents of
the user account for example if I want
to change the email because I can change
the email already with this copy with
but if I directly try to do this user
dot email is equal to something you can
see this is getting an error because
over here I've set the type of my email
to be a final final won't change so to
change it what I'm doing is copy with
if you want to understand the working
you can go through this function what it
really does
all right so in the copy with function
I'm going to pass in uid because that's
the new thing and the token now we have
not received the token so I'm going to
leave it empty for now the next thing we
are going to work on is the token so
here we are going to get the user
correct so how I'm going to get the data
let's go to this
thunderclient in our localhost you can
see this is our new object model
whenever we send the data we are
basically sending all of this
how are we sending all of this
we have our user account we are
converting this into a user model while
sending it we are converting this user
body
to Json to Json behind the scenes
encodes this to map function and two map
basically converts it into a map
so after encoding and all of that stuff
we send it to our server and our server
we just extract all of these things
since it's in a Json format and then we
just do our processes that's how the
whole process goes
all right so now to get the uid you can
see we have a Json bracket
and in that we have user so how are we
going to get that well first of all how
do we get the information to get the
information we always do res dot body
so whatever response we get that body to
get the
request you can see
to get the request data we are we are
using request.body but to get the data
we are going to get response.body
so in client side we are going to have
so in client side to get the data we are
going to use
response.body but in the client of
server side we are going to use
request.body great now response.body is
simply a string we need to convert this
into a Json format so that we can access
objects on it so how are we going to do
that well simple enough Json D code
with this function we'll be able to
convert our response.body to a proper
function or approve a proper Json file
or to a proper Json string
then here I want to access the user
property you can see here there is the
user property I want to access that
property
but I just don't want the user property
I also want its ID so I'm going to have
user and the id id here is underscore
you won't be able to see it but if you
go to the mongodb you can see it's
underscore ID so I'm going to pass in
another
thing like this
so we are taking response we are
converting it into Json accessing the
user property and in that user property
we have ID property and that will make
sure that we have the correct user ID
let's see what error are we getting well
we need to pass in this client so we'll
pass in the client as well simple enough
you see the usage of this provider now
I've just created it over here if I use
this author repository provider in like
hundreds of files I don't have to go in
those hundreds of files and then use
this client instead I just have to
modify it over here and everything else
Falls in place there were no errors in
any other file
all right so let's go down again
here add a break then add a default
and in that default we can just throw a
string error saying some error occurred
otherwise what you can do is just leave
it over here it wouldn't really matter
in our case at least if you want to do
Advanced error handling you can just go
ahead and do that for example case 400
case 500 all of those types but I'm not
going to go that deep in this
application
all right now how do I get the data how
do I store it in my state management
system so for that first of all I have
to create that state management system
so above at the top of my file I'm going
to create something known as user
provider this will keep track of our
user data
and this will be equal to State provider
this is another type of Provider
provided by riverpod
this will also have a ref but I don't
think I care about that and initially
the value will be null
also here let's give it a type of user
model
what is the all of this basically we are
creating a user provider which is of the
state provider
the problem is if we use this provider
it is just to read-only widget we can't
we can't just modify the values in this
provider to modify the values we can use
State provider or other type of Provider
like change Notifier provider all of
that but State provider is the easiest
of all
so I'm just going to use them and here
I've provided the type if I don't
provide this type and however this you
can see the type of the state provider
has become null but that's not true
initially the value is going to be null
why is it going to be null
because when we do our state persistence
in our main.dot file we are going to
check if the user is null that that
means that the user is logged in if the
user is not null that means that the
user is not logged in so for that we
wanted null but if I pass the value of
null to it it will cause me some bugs
some warnings some errors later on my
application so I'm going to provide it
with the user model type as well and
this is nullable if you just type this
it can't be null correct so just pass in
and empty this that means it's a
nullable
now if you heard about this this has a
type of user model now
obviously I want to use this user
provider in my application over here
because I usually like to keep my
providers separate from my business
logic so I'm going to do that in my UI
file usually you will use controllers
for that but I'm not going to go that
deep into this architecture this is a
very simple application the main point
of this tutorial is to get you familiar
with node.js and sockets so let's now
dive into it
over here though so how I'm gonna do
well work in the UI file after return
from return something from here correct
only then can I give some thing so I
have to change this type but what will
the type be I
that's a very complex thing because I if
there is an error I want to show the
error if there's a data I want to show
the data so do I pass in a map that
would be an ideal choice you have to
pass in a map but instead of doing a map
way I would like to create another model
called error model
with this error model you can well first
of all create a class
and you don't have to pass in model like
this instead models are much better than
Maps whenever you get the opportunity I
try to do that
they reduce the scope of errors and they
are much reusable as well
so your
this is going to have two properties
final string
error
final Dynamic data
this is a very you rare use case I found
for data data IU I usually try to give
types to everything that makes my code
much better but here the data can be
anything it can be a string it can be an
integer it can be a custom class as well
we don't know what we are going to
return so I'm just going to pass in a
dynamic over here now I'm going to
create a Constructor and that's pretty
much it if you want any other functions
we can get to it
all right over here though I'm going to
change the return data type to Future
error model
now we need to return this error model
so first of all we'll instantiate this
we are not creating this inside of the
try block otherwise the scope is limited
to this try block we want it to be
accessible even outside of this function
now here we are going to have error
model equal to error model then we pass
in the error which will be sum
unexpected error occurred
the data initially is going to be null
if all of our if our try block gets
removed I mean your we are going to
change the value but if that's not the
case then it will tell you that
something wrong happened I don't know
what but there is something wrong
but if there is a case 200 that means
everything went well make sure to not
add it over here if you add it over here
that will be bad but if you add it in
case 200 that means for sure everything
went well
so error is equal to error model
then we will pass in the error error is
going to be null now error here is not
showing null so I'm going to go here and
pass in question mark that means it can
be null
and we didn't have to do the same thing
for data because Dynamic can also be
null
but in the data IR we are going to pass
a new user
you can see right now
we are passing in a custom class which
is user model usually I mean we can just
pass in a string as well so that's why
the dynamic and in the catch block as
well we are going to have something
similar so let's just copy this line
remove the print warning and in your the
data will be null the error will be e.2
string
whatever we get over here that's going
to be the error all right that's pretty
much it let's see we have to return this
that's why we are getting an error so
I'm going to have to return this error
great now I can go to my login screen
where I've called this sign in with
Google function you can see the return
type is error model so I have to create
this asynchronous I'm going to await
this
and then get the error model so I'm
going to call this final error model is
equal to this then I'm going to check if
error model dot error is equal to null
if the error is there then we want to
show a snack bar so for that we are
going to use scaffoldmessenger dot off
context dot show snack bar and then we
will pass in a snack bar the content
which is going to be a text and it will
just be error model dot error
let's just pass a note and over here
it's going to be not equal to null so if
error model dot if error model dot error
is not null then this should happen but
of course we don't have build context so
let's accept build context and that
throws another warning but we'll get to
it
so here we have it now you can see do
not use build context across the async
gaps to avoid that what we can do is
final
s messenger is equal to
scaffoldmessenger dot of context let's
put it here we'll take the S messenger
and put it over here so now the error is
fixed we have used context before making
the asynchronous call and then we are
showing a snack bar but if there is no
error then what should we do and
actually I like it this way better I'm
just going to put this in the else block
so if the error model dot error is null
that means everything was successful
that means data has some value what are
we going to do
well I just want to go to the home
screen so I'm just going to create
another screen called home underscore
screen dot dot
import material dot create a stateless
widget
and then home screen this is going to be
a scaffold
save this much
also here in our body we are going to
have a centered child text
which is just going to be
reading from our River pod so we are
going to have consumer widget
and this will have a widget ref
everything we have done
so now in the text what are we going to
add well I just want to check for now
that the email is correct or not so I'm
just going to have ref dot watch user
provider Dot email
and this has to be not nullable that
means that the user provider now has
some value and it obviously has some
value because we went to the home screen
but before navigating to the home screen
we also need to make sure that we store
it in our user provider how are we going
to store it well simple enough we are
just going to use ref so we're going to
have ref dot read user provider
over here if I type this you can see I'm
not getting any option to edit it what
should I do it's just showing me the
values of the user model the properties
available on user model because this is
of the type user model
to to make some changes you will have to
add dot Notifier here and then you can
update the value you can see now we are
getting different options now I can call
Dot update and now I can update the
state so the state can be error model
Dot
data
that's pretty much it
they should update it now I have to go
to the next screen so again I'll have to
create Navigator here otherwise the same
message warning that we'll get
we need to avoid that
so we'll have Navigator
dot of context obviously we'll have
Navigator replaced later on when we use
some package so that we can have our
proper routing done
but for now we will just have Navigator
dot push
then we will pass in material page route
we'll get a context and here we just
need to return on the home screen
I can ignore the warnings for now or I
cannot let's just check not ignore it
I'll save this much I'll have to start
my server I exited it so I'm just going
to run it again I'm also going to run my
web version
and see if it's working or not and I
just realized I've launched Chrome on a
wrong version I have to launch it on a
3000 Port so I'm just going to run the
command that we already earlier had
which is this
flutter and Dash D Chrome web Port 3000
and we are running this on 3000 but our
server is running on 3001 that's a
keynote if you run both on 3000 that
will be a scope of error all right so
our app has launched let's go via sign
in with Google and you can see it sends
us XML HTTP request error now why am I
getting this error well that's basically
because of an error known as course
cross origin restriction basically this
is a very multi-platform app
you can run it on Android app iOS web
whenever we are sending HTTP request you
can see we are sending it from web
we can't share it you know
from web from Android all of that so to
solve this error we will just have to
close our server and run npm install
course
God's issue is a very major issue I mean
it just happens to everyone so make sure
to add that over here we just have to
import it first so we'll have constant
cores is equal to require course
if you want to know more about course
you can check out the web it's a pretty
big thing I can't explain it all
together over here
over here I'm just going to use app dot
use and then pass in course
and since we are here I realize another
error that we might have made
we have to go to the user model here
and in the from map function you can see
everything is correct except the uid
part because uid is not really uid
it's underscore ID you can see it in our
thunderclient as well if we just go to
over here everything is correct except
underscore ID we want the underscore ID
as well correct
so here instead of having uid we are
going to have map underscore ID
now I can restart my server
okay I have to restart my server not use
this
I can go to the index.js file and
instead of using cores like this I have
to use it like this as a function now
save this much I'll try to run the app
on web again I'll restart the app
then I'll click on sign in with Google
and you can see rewind contacts at the
rate gmail.com showing up now if I go to
the home screen and your type in ID just
to make sure uid just to make sure it's
correct
and I have to restart it
of course when you restarted the state
didn't process we have to work on that
we are going to do just that after
testing this out we're going to click on
sign in with Google
and our ID is showing up as well that
means everything worked now the next
part is whenever we restart the app we
don't want to come here if we are logged
in we want to stay logged in if you're
not logged in we don't want to stay
logged in come on the screen let's get
into it so how is this entire State
persistence thing going to work out well
I'm going to draw a diagram to explain
that to you well again this is our
client side this is our server side and
now we want to process the state so
obviously we've done the login process
we have sent it across then we've got
our data but that's all is over we
understood the problem as well but now
to process the state what we're going to
do is first of all whenever we log in we
are going to send that data across but
here when we do our login processes for
example when we do it in our index.js
and in the auth router sorry if we come
over here let me close the terminal here
we'll be generating a JWT which is Json
web token this token will allow us to
securely
store the user ID within ourselves and
verify if it's a correct user or not
so here we will generate a JWT and send
it across to the client side so when we
got here we are going to send this
across but with a catch we are also
attaching our JW
t with it so we are attaching our JWT
with it as well now over here in our
client side and this is the server side
so whenever in our client side we get
the JWT we are going to store it in our
local machine that means in the device
for example if you are on web we are
going to store it in the local storage
of web if we are on Android or iOS we
are going to store in the local storages
of those devices this wjwt will get
stored here and then whenever the user
quits the app or suppose here we restart
our app we are going to check whenever
the restart happens that means whenever
we get to the root of this file whenever
we start our application here we are
going to check
if the JWT is there or not in our local
storage if it's not there in our local
storage well we are not logged in but if
it is there then we want to get the user
information as well because ultimately
if I just sign in with Google because
ultimately I want to display some
information on my web page that's not
going to happen in our application but
in case you want to display a profile
picture let's suppose so after you
restart the app and the user is logged
in you could get to the right screen as
well but you don't you won't have the
user data in your provider right because
we are adding to a provider after we get
the user information from our auth
repository that means over here here we
are creating a new user sending it over
going to the login screen you're getting
this and reading from here
but that won't be the case when we
restart the application when we restart
the application we'll directly come here
we'll check okay there is no user we'll
go to the home screen a login screen if
there is a user okay let's go to the
home screen but where is the data where
are we storing it in our user provider
we are nowhere storing it so exactly
we are going to
fetch the user information with that JWT
that's why we are using JWT JWT will
securely
process that user ID that we are going
to sign it with you'll see later on in
our code but with that we are going to
sign our JWT and when we send it to the
server again to fetch our data we are
also going to pass in JWT so all of this
stuff has happened now let me erase it
off so all of that stuff has happened
now for State persistence we will send
across our JWT and in our server side
we'll make some code so that it can send
it across again and give us the user
data so after we have this user data we
can access our application pretty simple
correct now let's get into it we are
going to go to our auth router so let's
quickly go there where is our auth
router
yo and here we are going to well first
of all create a Json web token so for
that we have installed a package correct
now you know JWT is just for securely
transmitting information so and just to
mention why are we using this securely
transmitting information not directly ID
we can store the ID as well in our local
storage but if we use the ID there's a
great possibility a hacker or
someone else might get into your phone
crack your phone and just see the local
storage of your application so we don't
want that we always want to secure it
that would be really good as well
correct now over here I'm going to have
JWT and will require it saying Json web
token JWT is just short but this is the
package name Json web token now I'm
going to use this JWT and as I said we
are going to sign it with something
which is our ID so we already have the
method for it you can see sign so always
we need to provide JWT you can consider
JWT like a wrapper around some
information so with JWT we will get a
random generalized random generated
token but we want to display something
correct I mean not display but we want
to get some information based on it
so for that we are going to have jwd DOT
sign
then we are going to pass in the ID and
the ID is going to be user dot
underscore ID
now let's understand why we did this
over here we found the user whatever
user we had in Mongoose with the same
email we've already used that now here
we are just checking if there is no user
that means we need to create the new
user so we have saved it and then where
you we are assigning it to the same
variable right so we can use
user.underscore ID if the user is newly
being created then it will save it if it
already exists we already have that same
user variable there
now here I'm going to have constant
token equal to JWT DOT sign
having this I can just take this token
and pass it along with our user and
that's why we had this object created
otherwise you could have just done user
and it would work just fine but we want
to do we wanted to send token as well so
I did this
now as we're here we can also create
another route which is to get the user
data as I mentioned already over here we
need to get the user data so I'm just
going to create another route called
authorouter.get we are using the get
request here
because you want to get the user data
here we use the post request because we
wanted to send some data to our database
and here I'm going to have just slash
then we are going to have something
known as an auth middleware which are
going to create just now and then we are
going to have async request response
and then this is all of our code our
route so basically whenever we access
localhost
3000 but with only Us flash we don't
want anything else slash API slash sign
up is not required we only
required slash that time we will use the
Slash and you can have multiple routes
with this lash for example you can also
have auth router dot post but this part
needs to be different otherwise this
part needs to be different but it has to
be different
you can't have two routes with the same
URL right I mean the server will get
confused
all right now what is this author
middleware well auth middleware as I
mentioned
you can guess it it's a middleware so
let me get my illustration quickly so
here we are going to have our middleware
obviously as I mentioned this is the
middleware part but in this middleware
whenever the client sends some data it
will come over here now in our
application we are going to have a
feature wherein the logged in users will
only be able to see certain types of
routes for example document only the
logged in user will be able to view the
shared documents will be able to create
new documents all of that stuff so we
need to make sure that we add a layer of
protection to check if the user is
authenticated or not so if the user is
authenticated then only we can proceed
forward now of course we can put that in
every route
for example if I have this route I can
here get the user's ID from the header
and then
check and buy header why not body
because get requests don't allow body I
mean we are just getting the data so
what's the use of body but there is
something known as headers so tokens are
generally sent from the header now with
this header
we can get the user ID and then check in
our database if that user already exists
if the user exists that means that the
user is authenticated if the he is not
then they're not authenticated all of
that stuff also we'll have to check
something regarding the token correct
because we want to know that the user is
logged in or not I mean the user can
just log in and then click on logout and
after that we we don't know if the user
logged out correct so for that purpose
JWT will help us and we'll create all of
that in Auto middleware we won't do it
in this route of course we can do it in
this route but it wouldn't make sense to
do it for hundreds of routes correct
so here we are going to get some data we
can access that auth middleware so this
is our auth let me create that a so this
is our auth middleware
after we get that we know if the user is
logged in or not if the user is logged
in then we can perform a task
accordingly if not then we can just say
the user is not logged in I don't know
what you're telling
so let's go here and create the auth
middleware in our server we are going to
create middlewares
and this auth router that auth
middleware that we are going to create
is a very important thing in our
application
you can understand that right away
because on this our entire application
is going to depend because logged in
users will only be able to see the
Google sign in button no other routes
they'll be able to access so this is a
very important feature
if you didn't understand make sure to
leave a comment and I'll try to explain
it to you again
anyways now let's create a function for
authentication we are not going to use
Mongoose for it because well obviously
Mongoose has to do something with
mongodb
we don't want to do anything with
mongodb so here I'm going to have my
auth middleware it's going to be a
simple function
and it's going to be async request
response next
and then since it's async we are going
to have a try and a catch block
then here we are going to first of all
access the token and we are going to get
the token here from the request dot
header so we can have constant token
is equal to request as I mentioned
request
allows us to view body allows us to view
header so this is the header and through
the header we are going to pass
something known as a token and I'm going
to call this x auth token I like to
generally call this I think it's the
Convention as well I'm not pretty sure
about that
anyways you can name this whatever but
make sure later on in your application
whenever I use this x auth token you
have to replace this with your own token
I mean with your own line for example if
you type in token you want this to be
token not xox token then
then here you can check if there is no
token mentioned that means there's some
problem because you have not mentioned
any auth token so we can just return
response dot status
401
why are we having four zero one because
four zero one means no authorization I
mean the user is unauthorized that's why
you're using from 401 if you use 400
it would make sense a bit but it still
doesn't clearly make sense because 400
means bad request
so here I'm going to pass in 401 no uh
authorization so we are just going to
have a Json and here we are going to
type in a message if you want you can
have an error as well but I'm going to
go ahead with message and I'm going to
type no auth token
access denied
now if there is no token then we are
going to return it so if there is no
token mentioned then we are returning it
that means you are getting out of the
function so we can use the guard Clauses
technique here and obviously just
continue along
so here we are going to have constant
verified so that we verify now how we
were going to verify the token it's in a
JWT format
you remember we are sending the data we
are getting the data back JWT we are
storing it in a local machine
and then we are sending this data again
to our server let me remove the arrow so
that it's not confusing so we are again
sending our data
the JWT to a server through the header
I'm X naught token is exactly that JWT
so how are we going to verify that JWT
is a gibberish format it's not a real ID
how are we going to do that well
obviously we are just going to have JWT
dot verify method on it now let's access
JWT as well so we're going to have
constant JWT is equal to require
Json web token and now we have access to
this I can just call verify method now
in this verify method first we need to
pass in a token so our token is this
and then we need to provide it with a
key so if you go here we have made an
error already here in the sign method it
requires a payload
which is our ID
and a secret or private key this secret
or private key I need to mention now
what is the secret key going to be well
it's just going to be something you can
access your uh JWT with for example if
you want multiple gwts in your
application
it's not just for you know storing or
securing the information or password it
can be literally anything correct
so here we are assigning the key to it
so this is the password key if you want
later on for a document for example you
can create document key you are not
going to need this in our application
but for password we do need it so we
will provide password key and exactly
that we need to mention over here as
well so that we can verify it then here
we are going to check if not verified
then we are going to return dress dot
status again 401 because it's
unauthorized Json
message
token verification failed try again
later
or authorization denied you know this
seems like a very good message
all right now after having this if the
user is verified
then finally we can just do request dot
user is equal to verified dot ID
what does this mean well
here we are basically telling that
the request parameter that we have can
now have a new object on it this is how
objects are used if I have not mentioned
it already request dot user is equal to
verify Dot
ID not index of verify dot ID
so
if we go over here and we have the auth
middleware with us only when we have the
auto middleware with us
and the user is authenticated here we
can just do console.log request dot user
and it will print out the ID of the user
because your
we have
stored request dot user as verified.id
so what has happened is we add our again
big box
your event we are checking if there is
authorization we are storing some
information which is our ID as
request.user then we are going here so
it already has that information that
request.user is this if you try to use
it to a year it will give you null or
undefined something like that so you
don't want that so obviously only when
you use auth middleware will you be able
to so here we have done that and
similarly we are going to do for the
token as well so we have we are going to
have a request.token equal to token
and now
here we are going to have a catch block
saying res dot status 500.json
error and here we are going to have e
Dot message
great
now you might have noticed that we have
an extra parameter here which is next
obviously this is not an Express related
route so this is a middleware now in the
middleware I mean this comes in Express
but it's in the middleware of the
express route so
we also get access to next so we can
call next over here which is a function
what is this function well when we go
from our client to us uh to our
middleware
we are having our verifications like if
there is no token this then if there is
a token then we can move forward so
we'll have verified jwt.verify
then you're having a check if it is not
verified then we'll return all of this
and if it is verified then we are going
to have all of this done but how does a
server know that we won't go next I mean
we won't go over here we don't have to
go over here
all of this can happen but we won't go
to the next part even if it is
successful if we don't add this line
we won't be able to go over here because
our middleware doesn't know we have to
go and when do we have to go only after
all of these attempts have been done
only then do we have to go next so we
have our added next over here
all right now having done that let's
export this don't forget it we won't be
able to access it
then we can take this auth middleware
come over here and import that auth
middleware great now that we have access
to it we can use Mongoose to get the
user data that's why what I had
mentioned right so here we just want to
get access to the user so we'll have
access a user and how did we get access
to user well this line correct I've
named it const instead of let because
I'm not going to reassign it I'm just
getting the data I just want to get the
data and send it across
so I'm just going to use the same thing
user Dot find one I can use that so I
will avoid
user dot find but here you can see find
find one find by ID which one do we use
well we can use find and then find one
of course because there is going to be
only one user with the same ID and then
we can have underscore ID as
request dot user now this should work
but I'm not sure if it will work because
ID is of the type object ID that I would
already mentioned to you but here it's
of the type string so you might have to
check that but another approach to this
is just using find by ID option you
already have the ID why don't we just
use find by ID option and then we can
have request dot user and that's it
that's all we need to write now we just
need to send it across so we'll just
have to pass in user
and here we also need to pass in token
now what is this token going to be well
request.token simple
because here in our auth middleware we
are setting request.token as token so we
already have access to it but here I'm
not doing request dot token like this
you can see there's an error
so I have to do it like this only when
the key and the value are same for
example if this was this then only we
could do this now if you seriously want
to do it and think it's cool no problem
you can just do constant token is equal
to request dot token and then do
something like this this will also work
but
just to make sure anyone reading the
source code understands this properly
I'm just going to do this
great now after having this of course
you can have the try and catch block
wrapped around I'm not doing that now
you get the gist of everything that I'm
doing
so I'm going to skip a bit of steps here
now I'm going to close all the save file
go to my auth repository file again
now over here we are going to have
something really similar so I'll just
copy this entire function for your
practice I would recommend you to not
copy and paste this if I start copy and
pasting the tutorial will be much
shorter so I'll keep copy pasting but it
would be highly recommended for you to
type this all code
so that you can create your apps in the
future but even before doing that let me
just remove the sauce
I'll go up here and as we talked about
in the client side where in the login
side you can see we have a body user
account.2 Json and all of that good
stuff
here we are going to you do
useracount.copy with and also have
access to token and this token is going
to be very similar to this but instead
of having you know user underscore ID
we're going to have token and this has
no ID it's just token
all right so now let's just try to use
our ThunderClan to do the sign up
process I'm going to click on send and
you can see user is there and token is
there and this is a pretty big token
this has just
converted.i user ID to gibberish
so let's close this off and we have
access to the Token now whenever we get
the stroke and we want to make sure that
we store it in our server in our local
storage how we going to do that we
always obviously don't know how to store
it in our local storage so for that
we're going to use a plugin called
shared preferences
after installing that there's no other
process required don't worry about it we
will just go to a repository and create
another called local storage local
repository or
I think a better name would be local
storage Repository
and in this local storage well first of
all create the class
and then we are going to have
our function well it will just be two
function void
set token
so here we are going to have well this
is going to be asynchronous so we'll
have shared preferences
preferences is equal to await
sharepreferences dot get instance and
then we are just going to do preferences
dot set string
your path in X auth token
and then pass in the token so this is
going to receive a token from here and
paste it over here so what are we doing
here well first of all we are getting
the instance of shared preferences this
is how you get it you can't do something
like this to get the instance that's
just wrong because
you just can't have it
so here we are receiving the token
because we are going to call it here
whenever we call it here we are going to
pass in our token we don't have access
to it as a local class
then here we are going to have shared
preferences is equal to await shared
preferences dot get instance we got the
instance of our preferences now we can
call multiple methods on it we can call
get the string set the string set
Boolean whatever value you want to set
we want to set a string so we will pass
in the key of it X such token don't
confuse it with the value of our server
and our server also we are going to use
the same value X Hot token but just to
reduce you know
usage of many strings I'm using or exot
token if you want you can even call this
token but
when we get the string we want to use
this exact name we don't want to falter
so let's just keep one name exhaust
token for all of that and now we've set
the token that's all we have set it to
our local storage now we need to do this
for get token as well so we are going to
avoid get token we are going to remove
the pattern thesis we don't want that
anymore it's just going to be a single
line function so we are just going to do
preferences Dot
no it's it cannot be single line because
we want this shared preferences get
instance line so here we are just going
to have get
string X auth token this doesn't require
anything else after we get this
we obviously need to return this string
so let's return
this after having strain token is equal
to preferences dot get string await this
this can be null so that's fine
you can just return this token
over here the return data type is going
to be string
and since this is async we are going to
have future string and this apparently
doesn't require a weight so let's just
remove that
so here what have we done well we have
created instance of preferences now we
are just calling get string on it which
can be null because
this string might not just exist we have
made some error or the user is opening
the app for the first time and logging
in for the first time
then we are just returning the token
great now we want to use it over here so
what are we going to do well we are just
going to take it from The Constructor
first which is local storage repository
it is a package I mean this class
doesn't know about local storage
repository instead of creating a whole
new Cloud instead of calling it as an
object I would prefer to use Constructor
so that it's the unit testing is much
more easier
so you will have local storage
repository again make it private then
here we are going to have required local
storage repository local storage
repository and then just finally have
underscore local storage repository
equal to this local storage Repository
now we can take this local storage
repository go down
and your have local storage repository
dot set token and this new token is
going to be well the new user's token
simple enough
we add the new user we copied it with
this uid and with this token Now new
user has access to this token or
otherwise you could have just taken this
from here and pasted it over here but
what's the use of it
just writing more code right so just use
new user.token and there we have it now
we will go up here pass in the local
storage Repository
simple enough
now let's finally
create the get user data
route
so whenever
we have all of this done we want to get
the user data even now we won't be able
to you know
process the state because you have not
got the user data we are not checking if
the user is null or not we're not doing
anything of that sort so we need to get
this straight so whenever we get this
user data well first of all rename this
to get user data here we are going to
have the same error model created
then you're in the try block well let's
just remove
everything till year
because all of this we might need switch
case error handling all of that stuff so
here what are we going to have well we
want to get the token first so that we
can check if the token is null or not if
the token is not null then we can get
the user data if the token is null then
the user is not authenticated sorry
so here I'm going to have string which
can be null token is equal to a weight
local storage repository dot get token
now we have token with us now we can
check if token is not equal to null
then we are going to send the request so
we can just take this from here paste it
in your
even the switch cases methods and all of
that stuff we can shift it in your
Also let's remove one bracket that's
extra
all right so now here if the token is
not null then we want to send a response
and it's going to be a get request
because we want to get the user data for
to get the user data we created a route
which will just be host slash correct
now we are the body as I said get
request you can't send body if this was
post you could see we could pass in the
body but with get nobody so let's just
remove it so how do we send our token
well I already mentioned correct we are
going to send in X auth token and this
is the header you might have seen we are
sending this content type thing
here we also need to pass an exot token
and here we will pass in our token now
we may we know that it's not going to be
null so we can pass it over
now after this request is sent we are
going to have switch response dot status
code if it's 200 then what do we do in
case of 200 well we will just remove
all of this what we are going to have is
user model
user model
Dot from Json and then here we need to
pass in the source which is going to be
uses her dot body correct
nope that's the that's the wrong part
also this is going to be rest dot body
now why is this wrong
it does say from Json right so we need
to pass in our Json which is a sponsored
body but no that's not how we do it for
example if you come to our Thunder
client here again you might see this is
a response we are even passing in token
now if we just pass in this it will just
see two things user and token and none
of our
properties from user model Dot from Json
you can see that from Json calls from
map and in this from map we are just
doing email name profile picture all of
that stuff but in our map we are passing
in this entire object in our entire
object this isn't map at user this is
not map at token this is matpat user at
underscore ID at underscore name
so how do we fix this well simple enough
we are just going to pass in
this as response.body at user so
whenever we pass an user
it will pass in all of that stuff
correct but here comes another error we
can't use on string these uh brackets
so we will have to convert it to Json so
we will pass in Json in code then we
will pass this response dot body to it
don't pass user to it just pass user and
here we don't need to encode it we just
need to decode it
now you can see we have fixed the error
but this basically means that you have
returned a Json we have returned a Json
object from Json requires a string so we
again need to make sure that we encode
it so we'll just pass in encode again
here we will take all of these lines and
pass it over here
now it makes much more sense so what
have we done we have decoded the Json
that we got by sending the response we
are accessing the user property on it so
that we get all of this data
then we are encoding this Json and
finally calling user model dots from
Json which will read all of the property
in this user tab which is ID name email
profile pic
and that's why in from Json you can see
we have map at underscore ID because our
property here is map at underscore ID
but now what about the token token is
also very important in our application
how do we fix that we didn't get the
token we just got the all the elements
over here now to fix that what we are
going to have is dot copy with
and we need to pass in token like this
and this token is going to be token well
because we have the token already why do
we use the token that it's giving us
instead we will just take the token from
here
it's the same thing right you can also
do
all of this
and pass in token but instead of doing
that
just pass in this token it's just it's
the exact same thing we are passing in
the token in our index.js file we are
sorry in our auth router
we are having
auth middleware where we are storing
this request.header you can see we are
having this request.header
where we are accessing the token and
then sending it off to request.tok token
and we are sending this to our client
again
so literally the same thing you're
sending off to our server and back to
our client so why do I use that instead
just use dot token and we have it we
have our entire user ready now we just
need to send that data across which is
an error model
all of our stuff is done
now we can successfully go back to our
home screen where we are going to con we
are going to change this
not to our home screen sorry in our
main.dot file where we can change this
my app to a stateful widget
here in the NH State we are going to
call the get user data function because
whenever app our app restarts we want
this get user data to be there so I'm
just going to call the get user data
function here I'm going to create that
function as well so we will avoid get
user data
asynchronous
and now I will also have an error model
created right up there so I'm going to
have error model
error model
which can be nulled so as long as the
error model is null that means we are
fetching the data so as long as it is
fetching the data it's going to be null
but
so we can use that to display a loading
indicator but what if
the error model is
when the error model is not null we can
check the error model dot error if that
is enough if that is null there's
something wrong
anyways here we can pass in consumer so
that we can give our user data some
thing not user data sorry error model
something some value so for this we
obviously need to use auth Repository
to get access to auth repository we need
reference widget ref now how do we do
that in a stateful widget it's easy
your year and year
if you're wondering how I clicked with
three cursors you can just click on
option and it will select or deselect
for you
here I'm going to pass in consumer and
you can see error goes away this I have
imported flutter River Port that's why
this is now a consumer stateful widget
which is another
widget provided by riverpod itself and
it's equivalent to Consumer widget but
just like stateless widget and stateful
widget are different consumer and
consumer stateful widget are different
consume a stateful widget in our
consumer State Stores the reference the
widget ref for example in our login
screen if we go we add widget ref year
but in our main.file since you have
consumer State we don't have a widget
ref here it's already there present like
we have set Street present correct we
have such State present only in stateful
widget
if we do it in a stateless widget it
won't be possible without using another
widget you know which is stateful
Builder so in our main.file we are just
going to use reference dot read
and we are going to read from the auth
repository provider what do we want well
we just want the user data so give it
back to us and we need to await this
because get user data will return future
error model or error model is just of
the type error model
great
now we can check if error model
Dot
data and before that we'll have to check
if error model is not equal to null so
if the error model is not null and error
model dot data
is not null then we want to update the
user provider that means the error model
is not null it's not loading anymore
error model dot data is not null that
means
that there is data there is uh no error
so we are just going to use ref dot read
user provider dot Notifier so that we
can update it we have done this in the
login screen as well dot update and then
we want to update it with whatever user
data we get so we're just going to have
user
sorry error model dot data
and that's it this is of the type user
model if it's correct I mean if there is
no error because here in our auth
repository we've passed a new user
after having all of this done
I think we have all the parts ready now
we just need to check
and watch first of all so we will watch
here
saying final
user is equal to ref dot watch and then
pass in user provider
then if you're using watch in the build
method it's correct I mean you can use
watch and build read in
outside the build
so here you can check if user is not
equal to null
then you want the login screen otherwise
the home screen
sorry I typed it Traverse so I'm just
going to use user is null then login
screen otherwise home screen
now
also I've noticed all the code part is
done if there is no error obviously so
I'm just going to start my web on the
port 3000 otherwise it will give me an
error correct so I'll run it on this
port web Port 3000 and let's wait for it
so here I have the app ready I'm going
to click on sign in with Google
I'm signed in and you can see six three
or all that ID stuff showing up now if I
refresh my browser
I'm again going back to this screen you
can see even if I restart my app from
here
you can see nothing really changes
because well we are on the screen and we
will remain on the screen our part Now
is working successfully we have
completed State persistence now let's
try it on Android and iOS and if you
have any errors there well let's just
figure it out how to complete that so
I've launched the Android emulator and
here I'm going to click on sign in with
Google
and you can see null check operator used
on a null value it does sign me in but
it gives me a null check operator let's
see why we got that error and the null
check operator came here because of fear
sometimes the display name or the photo
URL can be empty display name is mostly
never empty but photo URL can be so to
fix that error all you need to do is
this with this the profile picture will
get stored with an empty string if you
want to give a default profile picture
you can pass that link of the profile
picture over here but I'm not interested
in that so I'm just going to give it an
empty string for the display name also
you can do the same thing if it is null
then it will give somebody if it will
give an empty string otherwise it will
give this value great now if I restart
it should start the application
now if I click on sign in with Google I
go to the next screen
if I restart the app
I'm still over here you can see that now
the next part of our application is
going to be the document part but before
that we need to work on something else
we want to work on the routing of our
application how are we going to manage
the routing in such a big application
correct
now in spite of it being a big
application you can use Navigator but
there's a problem with Navigator Dynamic
links basically whenever I go on the web
I want to pass in a certain URL that
will fetch me the current document for
example if I pass in uh whatever my URL
name is localhost 3000 let's say after
that I'll put slash document slash the
ID of the document and I want to go to
that document how am I going to achieve
this that won't be possible with
Navigator so we are going to use
Navigator 2.0 for that but I found
Navigator 2.0 a bit tricky to use and
explain so I'm going to use route Master
for it this is a wrapper around
Navigator 2.0
and it has a silly name that's fine but
this is much much more easier to use if
you are coming from react.js you might
know this as the react router Dom it's
so much simpler to use
it's very simple uh if you see an
example you might see
if we want
a dynamic link kind of thing
this is the link slash feed slash
profile slash ID and to use this we are
just going to use info dot path meters
ID and we have it it's so much simpler
and it's very similar to react router
Dom so I'm just going to copy this
and add it to my dependency I'm going to
close this I don't need this anymore I'm
going to run on my web because all of
these changes won't be visible on
phones correct it will only be visible
on our web so
I'll directly go to the main dot dot and
here I need to register my routes first
so instead of returning material up here
I'm going to return materialab Dot and I
just realized we can't run this we have
to run on a specific Port so let's run
on that Port here we have it web Port
3000 now here instead of returning
material app I want to return materialab
dot router we have all the same
properties except this home and a few
other
for example routes that is no longer
there now we have access to other things
like route
delegate router information
password router information provider all
of that stuff but what we are going to
use is two things route information
parser which is constant route
information parser and you can see
abstract classes can't be initiated to
fix that we need to return route master
information
parser
and with that we have the property
already passed in all we need to do is
pass in this constant route Master
passer and you can see initializes a
password that works in conjunction with
route Master delegate now we need to
pass in route Master delegate so here in
the router delegate property we are
going to pass in route Master delegate
and here it requires a route Builder now
based on this route Builder we are going
to generate and tell which route can be
used and what route can be used so here
we are going to get a context which is
very cool
and also here we can return the route we
want to use so I'm going to shift my
final user call in this context
and now I'm going to check if user is
not equal to null and
user.token Dot
is not empty
so if the token is not empty and the
user is not null that means that the
user is logged in so you want to return
a route that will work for logged in
otherwise you have to return a route
that will work for logged out
and here you can see it requires a route
map so we need to create this route map
I'm going to create this in a different
file altogether because as our app grows
we don't want to fill this UI part over
here right so I'm just going to create
another file called router.dot in this
router.dot
I'm going to create basically
as many routes I want AS Global
variables so I'm going to have final
logged out route
if equal to route map
and here I have to pass in a required
route called routes
and here it's going to be a map now what
is our first map route going to be it's
going to be slash so whenever we are
logged in what kind of routes do we want
to make accessible we're doing that
basically so router delegate will tell
us that if we are logged in what all
routes are accessible if you're logged
in then all what router routes are
accessible
so when we have slash we are going to
well get something you can see but I
don't really care about that still I can
take this
for this logged out route I don't care
so I'm going to have constant material
page
and in the child I'm going to pass in
login screen
so basically whenever we are logged out
what all routes do we want to display
what all routes can the user go to well
just the slash part so whenever the user
is logged out and comes to the slash
part for example localhost 3000 slash
then the user will only be able to see
login screen
and what other routes do you want
nothing else whenever the user is logged
out all other actions are prohibited so
we don't want anything else now I'm
going to copy this I'm going to create
logged in route
and here well this is going to be slash
again so whenever the user is logged in
what all routes do you want to display
so whenever the user comes on slash
localhost 3000 slash
and the user is logged in then we want
to show them the home screen
so I'm going to name this home screen
another route that we want is going to
be document but we'll get to it when we
start creating and go to the document
part for now logged out to Route has
slash and this also has slash same thing
but the only difference is if the user
is logged out this will be returned if
the user is logged in this will be
returned
and here we are going to pass the same
thing if the user is not tunnel and the
user token is not empty then you are
going to return logged in route
otherwise we are going to return the
logged out route
note
that logged in route will be able to
display all of the routes that you want
for example if you want other screens to
have the same logged in route for
example document on all of that stuff
you can have that here but this will
only include the F for the users that
are logged out to see an example let's
quickly restart our application
and your sign in with Google and as you
can see I logged in and I'm still on the
same route I was on localhost 3000 I'm
still on localhost 3000 that's how crazy
it is
and even if I try to refresh I'm not
going back that means it's working so
whenever we have slash it's working and
this flash also works and that's because
we are using ref.watch user provider
this is because of river pod as well so
whenever there is some change in the
route you can see ref dot watch runs and
all of that stuff happens it
reads the data from the user provider
correctly and thus we get all of this
output this is all together
now let's go back to our login screen
and wherever we use Navigator off we
need to replace this with routemaster
DOT off context
and with this what we can do is
Navigator dot push but now we just have
to pass in slash these have shorter
methods for example if we want to do pop
or we want to
go to the other screen and we want to
replace the other screen we can use dot
replace instead of using push
replacement all of that stuff just
replace very simple now if I restart the
app I'm still over here and all of that
stuff works properly now the next part
comes in creating our app bar where in
our app bar we will be able to log out
and also be able to create new documents
and then obviously we need to display
those documents so let's quickly get
into all of this stuff so now we will go
to our home screen and in here create a
very simple app bar this will be called
app bar
and here in the actions we are going to
put two things well first of all is the
icon button
and the second one is also an icon
button but the icon is going to differ
which is the first one is ADD so that we
can create a document here it will be a
constant and another one is the log out
button so that we can well log out
and here let's try to refresh our
application application I'll restart it
and here we have it now first of all we
need to remove this debug Banner so what
we can do is set debug show check mode
Banner to false and after that we can
come to the home screen and here change
the color of app bar so the background
color here can be K white color
after that the elevation can be zero
because right now there is a bit of
elevation
now we will just restart the app
and here we have it our app shows up but
the icon buttons are not showing up
because they are of the white color as
well so we need to change their color
that color can be color k black color
then we can copy this exact same thing
and paste it down here
great now if we reload our application
here we have both of these things cool
let's just make our logout button red
color so we'll go to our
colors.dot file and here create another
constant called K red color
so we'll call this K red color make this
colors.red and your K red color
then again restart our application and
here we have it the red color looks good
now let's work on the sign out option
it's pretty simple
now to make you understand how the sign
out function is going to work let me ask
you how what is the basis of the state
Persistence of our application token
right so what if we just remove the
token from the local storage
if I remove the local storage token
everything will just disappear right
that's the main point
so I just need to go to my auth
repository here create a new function
called void sign out
and here this will be asynchronous
obviously so here I'm just going to do
local storage repository dot set token
and I'm going to set it to an empty
string I've just removed the token so
here if I just show you the state
persistence code we are checking if
there is a token or not correct if the
token is not null then all of this is
happening but what if the token is there
I mean not there sorry
so here we are just throwing an error
and on the main dot dot screen we're not
handling the error or throwing some
error message here we are just saying
that if the data is not there then the
the user is not going to get any value
so this user provider will be empty thus
this will be empty and thus we will show
you the logged out route and that's
pretty much it if you just refresh the
application and obviously bind this
function
so we will avoid
call this sign out
and here I have
widget ref passed in
and here we are just going to call ref
dot read auth repository provider DOT
sign up it's not sign in with Google
sign up
also we need to clear off our data from
the provider because right now the
provider has some data we don't want it
to contain any data so here we will just
say ref Dot
watch
sorry ref dot read user
provider.nodifier dot update and we'll
again set it to null because here on the
main.f file we are just checking if
there is no null then logged in route
otherwise the logged out route that's
why we are coming to the home screen and
setting this to null easy
and why are we doing this well this line
will set the local storage token to
empty so whenever we next restart the
application
Arab
won't login but what if we are but I
mean we're already logged in whenever we
click over here we are logged in it will
just clear off the token but still there
is some data in the user provider so
we'll still be over here even though we
are logged out when we restart only then
will we go to the logged login screen
but before that we'll still stay on the
screen that's why this line is important
that will make it null and when it's
made null
here this part will also run again and
thus we will get the logged out route
if I just run this again
I'll click over your uh let me just take
this and pass it in over here
so it will be something like this we
passed in the ref successfully now
restart the application and then click
over here and you come to this sign in
with Google Now if I just restart the
application you can see I'm signing in
with Google but when I click over here
it didn't even ask me for my email or
anything the reason for that is I have
not signed out with Google you can see
here I signed in with Google
and that's all I had to do but from here
I even need to sign out right so for
that what I'm going to do is await
Google sign in DOT sign up
and after signing out it will ask us for
the email and stuff again
so that's pretty cool now I'm not going
to sign out and do stuff again but that
was the basic point now the next part is
whenever we click over here we need to
create a new document and go to the new
document so for that
before anything else we need to create a
document screen correct so we'll just
create that we'll call this document
underscore screen dot dot so we'll
import material dot I know this is going
to be a stateful
consumer so I'm adding the stateful
consumer if you're wondering how I got
this well first of all let me type this
name document screen if you're wondering
how I got this consumer stateful snippet
I just added an extension
called
flutter riverpods Snippets you can
download it it's pretty cool
now to make sure these errors go away
import flutter River pod and you can see
all the errors go away now we need to
report return a scaffold here now also
there's another thing that we need to do
other thing is we need to get an ID over
here so every documents this document
screen is going to be used for every
document that we go through for example
there suppose there is a list of
documents that are shown here which we
created when we click on them we will go
to this document screen with a unique ID
and this document screen will be this
document screen of course we can't keep
on creating different screens for
different documents correct that would
be like really terrible I mean it won't
even work correct because we don't know
how many documents there are going to be
and for every document we can't keep on
creating screens dynamically correct
so this document screen will manage this
all so for that we need a string of ID
now here we need to pass accept this
through the Constructor so that we can
pass it from the screen that we are
getting it from which can be this part
whenever we click over here we generate
a new document ID and go over there
otherwise it can be from the list of
documents that we will show later on
over here in the center for now we can
just display you know
a basic ID so we'll have text ID
and that's it I think widget.id is
better
and then just save it all right now
let's get to the back-end part of all of
this stuff so whenever we click over
here we need to create a new document so
for that we'll have to do multiple more
tasks now our authentication part is
completed so we don't really care about
the auth repository anymore we'll have
to do all our stuff in the document
repository but before that we'll have to
create a route right and it won't be in
the auth.js file this is only for
authentication files so now we need to
create document.js which is
the document route and even the document
model correct because now we don't want
to store all of the data in user
collection we want to store it in the
document collection so let's quickly
design a document so what is our
document going to be like let's just
think about it well first of all it
should have the user's ID I mean ID of
the user who created this document so
that we know whom to whom it belongs and
later on we can fetch on this screen the
list of I uh documents of the user
then we need the time at which it was
created I mean it's not really necessary
but if you want you can keep this it
will be really helpful if you want to
expand this project later on but for me
I'm not even going to use it because
[ __ ] or DB will automatically arrange a
Tena order I like
then we want the title of the document
obviously initially it's going to be set
as Untitled document but later on the
user can even update that and finally we
need the need the contents of that
document so what all is written I mean
the bullet points the Bold text the
italicized text all of that stuff
so first of all we'll start off by
importing Mongoose so let's require
mongoose
after that we need to create a document
schema
we all we know all of that stuff because
we have already done that in the user.js
file so we'll have document schema how
do we create a mongoose schema well we I
already said that but
Mongoose dot schema
and obviously before we even forget it
let's just export this document scheme
away
now here we are going to have uid let me
make it small and uid will have which
properties well required should be true
type will be string
uid will always be a string correct
after that we will have created at
what is created at going to be well it's
going to be a date right but in flutter
whenever we will create our Json model
we will convert the date time object
into a number which is going to be
milliseconds since epoch so for that I'm
going to make this first of all required
and then give the type of number
after that we will have title
so your required will be true
and type will be string but also
that is going to be trim set to True why
because title is there I mean title is
in the input of the user whenever the
user inputs the title
I mean the user is doing it and the user
input can be risky sometimes so we
always need to make sure that we trim it
and then we want content
content will be of the type array and
here you might notice that I'm not
entering the required type as true why
because content does not necessarily
required for instance when we
create our application
or create a document sorry when we click
over here the content is going to be
empty so for that I can mention another
property called default so what do I
want in the starting so what if I don't
provide any value to content it's not
necessarily required I don't have to
give it away whenever I create the
document model
but
I want the default to be an empty list
so if I don't give it so that means when
I don't mention the content it will take
in an empty array and it will do the
executions further on based on this now
I need to create a document
which will be Mongoose dot model not
[ __ ] Mongoose dot model please
great now we want document which is the
name of the collection and we will pass
in our document schema
now I will just take this document and
Export this not document schema if you
notice this then you're well on your way
to go ahead now in the document.js like
always we are going to import Express so
we'll have constant Express is equal to
require Express
then we are going to have constant
document
which is equal to require
dot dot slash models slash document I'm
importing the model
then I'm going to create my own document
router so I'll have constant
document router is equal to require not
required sorry Express dot router
correct now I can go ahead now so I'll
have document router dot post
and here I need to mention the URL first
so I'll have doc slash create not URL
path
then the auth middleware
let me see if I can import it I can't
seem to import this so I think I'll have
to import it like this so I'll have auth
is equal to require not DOT slash
middleware slash auth
after that
we can have asynchronous request
response
and then we're going to have a semicolon
and I think I wasn't able to import
because I was missing the I was keeping
this parenthesis in between when I
removed that I will be able to import
great so now after this obviously the
try and the catch block right away we
are just going to mention the
catch block so I'll just copy this
paste it in here and now in the try we
want to create the document
so what is the document going to be well
let document is equal to new document we
are going to create the OB uh object of
the new document and then store it to
database very simple stuff we did this
for the user as well so if you want you
can pause and go ahead and try to remind
yourself how to do this
all right if you aren't able to do it no
problem it's still the start so we can
just follow along so we'll have created
that from the request.body why are we
having that because created at is time
based now since it's time based there
can be some Delay from the server from
the client side
from the client side when the data comes
and we post it to the server there can
be some delay due to which the created
add function I mean the created ad
variable will have different time zones
we don't want that delay so right away
we are just taking from the client side
and sending it to the server side we
don't want two different values in the
client and the server side that's why
now here first of all we want to pass in
the uid which is going to be
request.user you can see if it was uid
then we could have done it this way but
since its request dot user which
contains the ID of the user because we
add the auth middleware only
authenticated person will be able to
accept our application access our
application
now in the title well what should the
first title be it should be Untitled
document
all right whenever we create an uh a
document we want it to be Untitled
document and then we want created at
after that we are just going to do
document is equal to document dot save
and we want to do await
because it's asynchronous process
promise and then we can just do this dot
Json document
easy enough and document will
automatically generate the ID for us and
all of that stuff which will be really
helpful for us later on but here we have
it now we just need to export this
document router
and go to our index.js file where here
I'm going to use
I'll use it after auth router so allow
app.use document router the matter
doesn't really matter but auth router if
it's first I feel better
now
I can go to my
repository and your create document
repository dot dot file so here first of
all I'll have to create my class called
document Repository
then I'm going to have final client
underscore client then I'm going to
create a Constructor out of this so
let's quickly create that
and your I can't seem to use this
anymore so I'm just going to have client
and then client is
equal to client great
now what I can do is create a document
so which will be future error model now
we will just return error model just
literally everywhere except where we
don't want to handle the errors or
anything I'll do that in a few functions
but I'll let you know you'll have to do
it if you want your application to be
better
anyways so here I'm going to have
asynchronous a try and a catch block
because while sending the HTTP request
there can be some errors
and here I'm going to copy most of the
things from auth repository but again I
would recommend you to not copy and
write it on your own it would be better
for you
but here I'm just going to literally
copy all the boilerplate code I've
written all of that
so I would recommend you to write a two
but anyways we don't need all of this
stuff let's remove the bracket from the
bottom as well now let's save this much
so what do you want to do well we want
to share a post request we want to
import this host variable as well but
now here we want slash doc slash create
then we want the headers and now we'll
always need the token so we'll always
have to accept this from the parameter
we can't do this over here because I'm
not making ref calls in my uh repository
classes
but here I also need to pass in a body
correct so the body is going to be let's
just get it okay so the body is going to
be created at and now I'm just going to
send in date time dot now dot
milliseconds since epoch
also we need to Json encode this because
we are sending the body we can't just
send a map right we can't send an object
we want to encode it so we'll have Json
and code
and here also I'm going to encode this
now after I get my response I'll check
if it's case 200 if it's case 200 then I
don't want to do any of the stuff I want
my data to be very simply document model
and I will have to create that document
model as well so here I'm going to
quickly create my document model you can
see how helpful models are even in dot
even in Mongoose I hope you're getting
the hang of them so here I'm going to
have class document model what all stuff
are we going to have we have already
decided that in the document model in
our Mongoose file
a user ID created at title and content
let me just have this as well
so let's quickly type all of that out
final string title final string uid
finals list content and I'm not giving
this list any type you might notice I'm
not doing list of string I'm not doing
list of end we don't know what the type
is because it can be literally anything
it can not be just string you know it
can be anything that's how uh the
document that you're going to create
will work because there are going to be
bullet points there are going to be
a tick marks that is going to be well
Bolding italicizing changing fonts are
exchanging font family all of that will
be very different so it's just going to
be list which is dynamic
can have any value
also we are going to update Time created
at and finally the thing that we have
not mentioned here so let's remove this
now
it's useless now so we'll just have
final string ID
now we can
take this bulb icon generate a
Constructor we can take this bulb icon
generate Json serialization
but here in the from map function always
make sure that this ID is map underscore
ID don't change this uid now because
this uid will be the uid because in the
document we have created this uid
property which is the user ID but the ID
property
is the ID of the document uid is the
user ID of the document that we are
storing so make sure to change this
now we can save this and in the document
repository we'll have the data as
document model
Dot from Json res dot body and here we
don't have to do that Json encode and
decode thing because from Json will do
that but we had to do it earlier because
we had two things returning earlier
which if you go here I can again show it
to you the user and the token but here
we are just sending off
the document
great so now here let's remove all of
this
let's break it out and I think this is
pretty much it this is our function to
create a new document
so I can go to my screens folder in the
home screen and here I will create a
function called void create document
so what is this going to be well first
of all let's just make it asynchronous
because we are going to call the create
document function and then we are going
to first of all get the token because we
want to pass in the token we'll have ref
so let's get the ref
dot read and then we are going to have
auth repository provider Dot
I don't think we need auth repository we
need user provider
dot token and this user can be null but
now it cannot be null because we are in
the home screen we are on the home
screen only only when the token is not
null so we want to not get this null
check operator error
now we are going to get Navigator which
will be route master
dot off context we are not using build
context anymore
and we're using I mean sorry if you're
not using uh Navigator dot off context
you're using routemaster.off context
we also need a snack bar so we love
Navigator
dot off context then we are going to get
the error model which is going to be
await
ref dot read now we are going to read
auth repository provider and call get I
don't know why I keep calling auth
repository provider it's over and done
we need to create the provider for
document repository so we'll have final
document
repository provider
which is equal to provider
ref
and then we can return from this
document repository instance and then
client we can pass it in
easy now you can go to the home screen
and here we can pass in document
repository provider instead now we can
finally call create document and pass in
our token just calling the simple
function not
a very weird task
now after that we are going to check if
error model dot data
is not equal to null so if the error
model.data is not null then we are going
to use Navigator dot push
and push it to the document screen so
we'll have slash document
slash dollar
error
model dot data
Dot
ID
why can we use the ID because we know
it's going to be an instance of the
document model class whenever we use
data.id correct now we need elsewhere we
are going to have snack bar Dot
show
okay we don't need Navigator off we need
scaffold Messenger off I'm not sure what
I'm doing
so here we will have scaffold messenger
then we can do snackbar dot show snack
bar and then pass in snack bar
the content here is going to be a text
saying well whatever error is there
correct so we'll just have error model
dot error and now it cannot be null
because we have already made the checks
for it
great now we just need to link this to
our
button here so we'll have like this
create document pass in the build
context pass in the widget ref and there
we are
but now if we do that I think it will
create the document but it will tell us
that the route was not found if I do
this
okay we don't get anything
let's see if we get any error nothing
so let's go to our document model uh
sorry
in our document repository we'll go down
here and in the default we are going to
well
have the error handling part done so
that we know what the error is or you
can just even print it out but never
mind since here we don't need a break
after default but if you put in no
problem
here in the data we are going to pass in
null but the error is going to be
whatever data we got from here so we're
just going to pass interest dot body now
okay I think we didn't even restart our
application that's why it sent us the
error but anyways let's start it if you
do this you can see page document and
this unique ID
you can see it wasn't found so that
means it's working we got the unique ID
passed in and if we go to our mongodb
you can see that the document was
already present there
so now why is this route problem coming
in well pretty simple error
the reason for that is we have not
registered in the logged in route make
sure that you pass it in the logged in
route so here what we are going to do is
slash document slash ID
that's what you need to pass in slash
document that's what it is slash
document and then our ID
so this is the ID you need to pass in
this colon this is called a slug
so make sure that you pass it in and
then we get a route so we can use
constant material page and then in the
child we will pass in the document
screen and in the document screen you
want to pass in the ID which will be
route Dot
path parameters and there we are going
to access the ID
and this cannot be a constant so let's
just remove that
and this can be of the type string
nullable so let's make sure that it's
not nullable
or if there is what we can do is just an
empty string simple enough so here we
have it material page child document
screen so whatever we have passed in
here we need to pass it over here and
this is path parameters that means you
can have multiple IDs like this for if
instance if you want slash dollar
something else you can do that as well
but here the route dot parameter will
become
like this
it will become something else over here
so you have to pass in the same thing
after this colon
anyway so now after having this done
let's restart our application
and now if I well go back we don't want
to go on the document screen I'll click
on Create and you can see I'm coming on
this screen where our document ID and
we're not seeing anything else because
here I've passed in something else over
here and that's causing the error now if
I remove this out and refresh my
application close the file
also here I'll pass in localhost 3000
I'll click on Create and here you can
see I'm going to the other screen and
the IDS are similar that means that this
stuff is working the nav bar is also
gone cool stuff but as you could see in
the router.dot file even if we added
another part another part and click on
Saved then reload our file and do this
we go here but we are still on the same
screen even though we are here it
doesn't go to the other screen
so that's a really cool feature I like
it then we can restart our application
and whenever we go you can see it
automatically restarted and we came on
this screen cool
now I can again go to the localhost 3000
which is our starting port
now here we need to display all the
available documents I mean the documents
that I have created not to anyone else I
want the documents created by me so that
I can open them anytime I want
so let's get into it so now to display
them what I'm going to do is go to the
document.jsrav and your create my route
very first route called document router
dot get my very first get route in the
document file so here we want to pass in
the URL so I'm just going to pass in Doc
slash me
authentication
asynchronous request response
and the simple route creation
after that I want the try and catch
block
so here I'm going to have that very
quickly also I'm going to have this
pasted over here
now in the try block I want to get all
the documents created by me how am I
going to get that just think about it
did you get it if you didn't then simple
enough
you just need to do await document dot
find
and now we want to find all the
documents created by me if my user id
which is uid in the document I've saved
it like that correct the uid is saved as
request dot users ID I mean the uid over
here that's saved in the document
collection is the same as the
request.user that means the user ID then
we want to get them so we will find them
find will return to us a list of
document even if it is one document it
will return us a list of one document
and then we are just going to rest.json
and documents
good enough
now our route is created now we just
need to go to our document repository
and your create a very simple thing
we will just have something like this
but instead of creating a document we
are going to get the documents so we are
going to have get document so here we
are going to send a response so it's
going to be post
is going to be get actually and we don't
need to pass in a body the header is
going to be exhaust token and here the
docs slash me will come in not doc slash
create I want to get docs of mine
now switch res dot status code case 200
and then the error will be this but
before that we need to return the
document the rest dot body will return
to us
the list of all the document we don't
want to return a list we want to
well return one document from the model
and then put it in a list here if you do
that it will give you an error because
res dot body will be list and this
accepts a string not a list correct so
here first of all we'll have to create a
very simple model called document models
list let's call this documents initially
set to an empty list then we will do for
inti is equal to 0 I is less than
Json
decode response dot body
dot length
I plus plus
so what we have done we have decoded the
Json so that we can get the length
after we do decode the Json of res dot
body we can get access to the link so
what is the length of the list correct
we'll get that and we Loop through it
and every time we go through one object
in the
list
we want to add that so we'll have
documents dot add and we'll add document
model
Dot from Json exactly this line right
let's just pass in but instead of press
dot body we are going to pass in that
whole line that we had created earlier
as well it's going to be Json D code
response dot body at I but this will be
enclosed by Json encode
pass it in
and then add it in
also here we need to pass in document
Dot model Dot from Json
and then we'll pass in all of this stuff
because we want it to be a type of
document model correct now we can just
pass in documents over here
easy enough
after saving it I think
everything is pretty much done so for
this how are you going to do it well
there are two approaches you can take
there is a provider known as future
provider and robopod which will allow
you to uh
make your boilerplate less
but you can look into that in some of my
other videos but in this video I'm just
going to go ahead with a simple future
Builder
I'm going to go in the document screen
instead uh sorry in the home screen and
instead of having a centered text saying
this I'm going to have my big future
Builder ready this future Builder will
have Builder it's going to be context
and snapshot and a future which will be
ref Dot
watch and we'll have
document repository provider Dot
get documents then we want to provide it
with a token so what is the token going
to be well it's going to be ref dot
watch
user provider which can be null dot
token
a very big line indeed I know but we are
just watching the documentary repository
provider now we have instance of
document repository then we are calling
get document because we have that class
basically
and then we can
use ref.watch to get the token because
it needs a token
now here in the Builder what we are
going to have is very simple
if where we will check if
snapshot.connectionstate is equal to
connection straight dot waiting then
what do we do if the connection state is
waiting I want it to have a loader
showing up so I'm going to create my
custom chrome loader here which will be
called in the common tab in the widgets
folder called loader.dot
this loader will be importing
material.creating a stateless widget
we'll call this loader and this will
return a centered child of
circular progress indicator
this is also going to be a constant so
we'll save this much then we can take
this loader
return a constant
loader
after that we are going to
return
a list view Builder
which will have context and an index
and we'll see this much then we also
need an item count and the item count is
going to be snapshot.data.dogs.link
and this data here cannot be accessed
because you've not given future Builder
a type you need to give future Builder a
type which will be error
model import that and this can be null
and yeah we are getting this error
because it's not docs but it's data so
when we pass in data now the error fixes
now you don't even need this so you can
remove this line and it still works
so now in our item Builder first of all
I'm getting my document model because
well this is a list view Builder I have
the item Builder and we are have we are
getting list of documents correct now I
want to get a particular document so for
that I'm going to do document is equal
to
snapshot dot data dot data dot Docs
I'm not sure why I'm using docs
continuously but it's dot data at index
now I have access to the document so
what I can do is return
a card
of child Center and the text will be
Center I mean the text is going to be
document dot title
because whenever we see a card we want
the title to be there correct and we
need a style which will be constant text
trial
which will be font size 17. I'm going to
make it a bit bigger so that you know it
looks cool
also here we are returning so we want a
semicolon now I'll save this much and
see what I'm getting so I'll just
refresh my application
and here you can see Untitled document
these many are showing up which is
actually correct because I created many
documents to because I thought it was a
bug in my application
but with you if you created clicked on
this once then you might have just one
but anyways there are a lot of things to
fix first of all the height of the card
the height of the card right now is just
what the text size is I want it to be a
bit bigger than the text size correct so
for that I'm going to wrap my card
widget with a widget known as size box
so that I can give it a height of 50.
now if I save this much and again reload
my application
now it looks much bigger and much better
now I want to reduce the size of this if
I pass in the width over here it won't
work for example if I give it a width of
200 and save it and then restart the app
you can see nothing really works so I'm
going to remove this but give list view
Builder a sized box widget so we'll have
wrap with Widget call it size box and
then give it a width
of 600. now I'm going to save it reload
the application and here we have it R
doc R card is now 600 with
I want this to shift in the center right
so I'm just going to wrap this size box
with a centered widget and save it now
again restart the app and here it is in
the center pretty cool I also want some
margin from the top right even from here
even from here so what am I going to do
well I'm going to replace this sized box
with the container so that I can give it
a margin
when I don't have to give it a margin
I'm going to use a size box but
otherwise I will just use a container
now I'll have constant Edge insets Dot
only and from the top I want 10 of
margin if I restart now
you can see it looks much better it's
not stuck to our navigation bar which is
cooler
now whenever I click on this I want to
go to the document screen and well our
magic will start the document socket
connection
how are we going to achieve that very
simple enough we are just going to wrap
the center widget with a widget called
as Inkwell why am I using Inkwell
because I want the on tap property
and why am I not using gesture detector
instead let me show you if I restart the
app you can see whenever I click on this
right now is giving me this because I
don't have to wrap it with this centered
in the list view Builder let me remove
this widget I have to wrap it inside of
my card
because I want to
when I click on this one card I want
this hover effect to come in right now
it's for the entire screen if I restart
nothing shows up because I want to pass
in an on tap as well only then will the
hover and the splash effect come in when
I restart you can see all of this cool
cool things happening which is really
cool now whenever I click on this I want
to navigate to the document screen so
for that we are just going to use route
Master correct
so I'm going to create another function
here called void
navigate
to document
we are going to have a build context
uh
then the document ID as well because we
don't know what and where to move right
we want the document ID and we will only
have access when we know which card was
clicked so we are going to have
routemaster dot of context dot push
then we will use slash documents slash
dollar
document ID now why did I use push
instead of replays when I push I get
access to this back button but when I
use replace I don't get access to this
back button that means I cannot go back
I don't I it will replace the current
screen I want to push it so that you
know it's kind of a stack if I go back I
can go back but with the replays I can't
go back
there's no looking back now we can go
back
to our Inkwell widget and you have
navigate to document pass in the build
context pass in the document dot ID and
done now I'll restart my application and
whenever I click here I go to this
screen
if I click over here I go to this one
you can see all of these IDs are
different from each other
so this is the screen of our application
now the next part is over here creating
a nav bar and here we'll be able to
change our title
and we will be able to display you know
the Google Docs icon all that styling
stuff
after that we will get into our text
editor which is a cool thing because
it's so easy
let's dive into it really quick all
right so first of all I'm going to close
my terminal and close all the save files
and then I'm going to go to the document
screen and now let's think how our
design should look like this is how the
data design should look like well what
do we have here well first of all we
have an app bar which has a different
color than this because this is pure
white and by default flutter is not
giving us the pure white background
color then we need our editing tools but
before that you can see this line part
here that part is not because of the
elevation or anything that line is
basically because of the color so we
need to add that color below the app bar
as well but first let's start with the
app bar we want a Google Docs icon we
have already installed that in our
flutter project here you can see when we
were installing the Google logo and then
we want this text input field this is a
text input field not anything else
because you can edit this title and then
finally at the end we just want the
share icon should be very easy to do for
us so let's get started with it so here
in the scaffold I'm going to return an
app bar so let's have an app bar and in
the app bar first of all
we are going to change the background
color so we'll pass in the background
color as K white color and then
we want the elevation to be set to zero
now let's see how it's looking I'll go
I'll have to sign in and actually I
can't sign it because I logged in from
another Port see you when I go to the
3000 port
all right so our browser is there with
us now let's click on sign in with
Google here I have to enter my email
I'll see you after I log in here I've
clicked on a document and here you can
see I'm getting the ID and even the app
bar that's looking good now let's try to
make some changes here as well I'm going
to close the terminal now in the actions
because I want to add your
the share button so I'm going to click
on actions and then add the button
elevated button dot icon again we need
the icon button because if you go over
here we have the lock icon and then the
share button so let's quickly create
that on press will be empty for now then
we are going to have icon of icons Dot
Lock
lock not local
also I'm going to set a color to it so
let's pass in the color of K black color
after that save it this is going to be
constant
then here we need a constant text and
then it's going to be called share after
we share it and let's try to restart our
app
here we have the share button now we
need to decrease its size and stuff and
even before doing that let's just change
this black color to the normal color
that looks much better yep
now we just need to reduce the lock icon
size so we can have size as 16 and then
save it restart and this looks much
better now we just need to make sure
that we reduce its size to reduce its
size you're going to take two approaches
well give it a size directly by passing
in the style otherwise you can just
do Ctrl shift R wrap it with a widget
called padding and give it a padding of
8 then restart the app and if you see
this is looking better but I want it
much better so I'm just going to convert
it to 10 and restart again
as you can see this looks much better to
me now I want this to be of a different
blue color not the original blue color I
have to make some changes so I can go to
my colors.dot file
and here I'm going to create key blue
color which is equal to color dot
from rgbo
which means red green blue opacity so
it's going to be 26 115
232 1 and if you're wondering where this
color is coming from well it's just
extracted from the
Google Docs share button itself
so here in the button we are going to
pass in style as elevated button dot
style from and then we can pass in the
color of background so we'll have
background color as K blue color
sweet now if I restart the app and go
over here this looks like a more stylish
button now we need to add the title so
what is the title going to be these two
things the text input and the docs
button uh docs icon sorry
so let's quickly add them
below our actions we are going to have a
title and in the title we are going to
have a row in that row children
and the first child is the icon itself
so it's going to be image dot asset
and then we will provide the asset which
is acid slash Images slash docslogo dot
PNG
now let's see if this much restart and
here we have it now it's too big so
we'll decrease its height so we'll have
height as 40 and then save it again
restart the app
here we have the docks icon fitting good
enough
after having this I can leave a space
so I'll have constant size box width of
let's say 10 after which I can add
another one which is text field now
since we are in a row text Field Works
this way that it will try to get
everything in the row but we don't give
everything over here because this is a
docs icon so what are we going to do
about it well we have to wrap it with
expanded
but if we wrap it with expanded this
text field will go till here I don't
want that I want to give it a specific
width so for exactly that we are going
to add a size box which will have a
width and the width here is going to be
100 let's say then in the text field we
are going to pass in a decoration which
will be constant input decoration
and that will say that border should be
input border dot none
then there should be content padding and
the content padding will be
Edge
nsaids.only from the left side 10.
then save it restart the app
and we don't really see our text field
and we're not getting any error for it
as well
to give it some value what we have to do
is create a controller so we'll have
text field controller
it's called text editing controller my
bad then we are going to call this title
controller
which will be equal to text editing
controller and we're going to pass in an
initial value now what is the initial
value going to be we can pass it through
text argument this will be just Untitled
document
you later on we are going to use this so
that we can give it
the initial text of something else which
is taken from the database because even
if it's Untitled document in the
database you're storing it as Untitled
document right
but for now let's just keep this we are
also going to call the dispose method
here we are going to have
titlecontroller dot dispose
now we can take this title controller go
down and pass to it the controller which
is title controller now we can restart
the app and we have our nice text field
but 100 is too small of it so I'm going
to pass in 180 I'll restart and this
looks much better
I can change the document and everything
but still it doesn't look very good
because we don't know we have come over
here or this even exists right I mean if
I click on it it automatically starts to
serve uh like a cursor it puts on it I
wanted to have some border so for that
I'm going to add
Focus border so whenever the user clicks
on this they will see a border now what
will the Border be outline input border
and then we are going to have Border
Side let me have Border Side of Border
Side and the color is going to be K blue
color
let me put some trailing commas and then
restart the app now if I click over here
you can see this works well when I focus
it it looks good now below this
part here
I want to add a border you can see that
there is a border here so that there is
a clear distinction to make that clear
distinction how are we going to do it
well appbar doesn't support anything
like that except it has an argument
called
bottom with bottom you can pass in a
container
but the problem is bottom accepts a type
of preferred size widget we can add to
it an app bar and it wouldn't throw us
an error but I don't want an app bar I
want a simple border so for that I'm
going to create my own preferred size
and in that I want to pass in a child
and a preferred size Now what is my
preferred size going to be well it's
just constant size Dot from height 1.
so whatever with is there keep all of it
and I just want to increase the height
by how much one
and there is a child now the child is
going to be a simple border so we can
have container decoration box decoration
and we can pass in a border which will
be border dot all
now here what color are we going to
choose well it's going to be gray color
correct so again let's go to our colors
here we are going to have variable K
gray color if you're wondering why I
don't have
constant here you'll understand right
now when I use colors.gray
dot shade 800 this is not a constant
shade 800 is not a constant it is
variable if I put constant over here you
can see it throws an error so I'm going
to pass in variable K gray color now why
do I want shade 800 because when I use
cake gray just the gray color it's too
prominent I want it to be a less
prominent one so I'm going to use the
Lesser shade
now I can take this
pass it in here and what is the color
going to be well okay gray color
also here I want the width to be
minimized so I'm just going to pass in
0.1 now we are getting this error to
resolve this error we just need to push
the preferred size at the top and not at
the
year
because widget
child should always be at the last
that's what the error prompt says to us
so let's just follow that right
now if I restarted everything looks good
but now still there is not too much
padding from the top over here so in the
app bar uh wherever we had our app bar
let's go at the top
and in the title we are going to wrap
our row with padding
after we wrap the row with padding here
we just need to pass in dot symmetric
and vertical we can do it
let's say 9 and then we can restart our
app now this looks much more better
there is some padding from the top and
it looks much more organized all right
having this done now we need to set up
our controller or you can say our text
editor the main part of our application
how are we going to do that well
obviously we can't use the text field
over here that's just very useless so
for that
editor we are going to use something
known as a quill editor and what is
equal editor well you can find it here
flutter coil 6.0.0 published just three
days ago so this there might be some
code that might be a bit different from
uh what I've written earlier because I
wasn't using 6.0.0 but let's hope not
anyways
this flutter quill uh is like built on
coil coil is something used in some
JavaScript Frameworks have built it I've
built a text editor with the quill.js
itself and even with react quill when I
was using react it's a very powerful
tool and I can completely rely on it if
you want to check out you can check this
out but we're going to use this flutter
quill it's going to provide us with nice
widgets and controllers which will make
our lives much more easier now to set it
up well let's just go to the
documentation
you can see they've literally provided
the entire code we are going to use so
let's just copy it
in the body
we are going to paste it now we need to
import this so let's import quill
we need to create this controller and
also remove this container Let's see we
don't have that option to remove the
container so let's quickly remove data
by ourselves now we need to create the
controller for our quilt so how are we
going to do that you can check out the
documentation again it's written over
there but what we are going to do is
while importing quill first of all we
are going to use it as coil okay
because this has some package which will
interfere with our material package and
we don't want that correct now we can
just use quill like this
now let's create this controller so
we'll have coil dot coil controller
and let's call this underscore
controller let me have well here
fast in
which will be will controller
dot base it
thank you
let me pass this in easy
also make this final for now later on we
are definitely going to change we are
going to make all of these controllers
late when we use the socket i o part but
for now let's just keep it the way it is
now we can take this controller and we
have it now let's try to restart our app
it will or it should throw as an error
it doesn't
it shows us the toolbar correctly which
is great
but now you can see we are not getting
any
text editor as such Why
well it's because of the sizing issues
what I'm going to do is
over here remove this comment first and
instead of expanded and like this what
I'm going to do is wrap this widget with
another widget known as
a sized box size box which will give it
give it a fixed width which will be 750
then we can restart our application now
you can see we have certain within our
application it might not be visible but
the cursor is very visible now to make
this more prominent we will have to wrap
it with the
card right so that we can give it a bit
of elevation and change its color so the
quill part
we are just going to go ahead and wrap
it with the widget card
now let's restart
you can see some changes it's much more
elevated and visible but now we are
going to give it a color color is going
to be K white color that's probably the
default color as well then we will
increase its elevation to 5 then restart
the application and it's much much more
easier to read I mean much much more
prominent but now it's stuck at the top
and it's not even centered so to make it
centered first of all you can wrap this
column with centered widget then restart
it's at the center now then we need to
leave some space from the top so we'll
have constant size box height
10 and let's leave some space between
these controllers as well so now it
looks much better now we just need to
wrap it with a
padding widget because you can see our
cursor is right over here we want it
somewhere over here so for that we have
to wrap our quill editor with padding
widget not our card widget because if we
wrap card this will get padding from all
of these sites we don't want that we
want only from the square editor so I'm
going to wrap it with a widget called
padding
and uh
padding is going to be 30 from all the
sides
now this looks much better you can type
anything you can bold it italicize It
Whatever good stuff you saw in the intro
as well
you can also pass and Snippets of code
if I have not already told it to you
anyways so if I remove all of this let's
remove it
we have a text editor set up now the
next part is whenever we change the
stuff over here we want it to change in
our database as well and it should be
reflected as well so let's get into it
so to update the title what we are going
to do is close all the saved documents
all the files and then we're going to go
to
document.jsrout and here create a new
route well it's going to be very similar
it's going to be the same post request
so let's copy this line again if you
should type it but here I'm just going
to do plots slash dog slash title then
here I'm going to take in the ID and the
title from request.body because every
document will have their own ID I want
to go to that document find that ID and
then update their title correct
I mean I will find the document by their
ID and then update their title so here
what I'm going to do is
constant or
document is equal to
a weight document
dot find by ID and update this is
another method basically we find by ID
and then update whatever field we want
to update so here I'm just going to pass
in first of all the ID and then I'm
going to pass in the title
and that's pretty much it now we have
updated the document I just need to do
press.json document because I don't even
have to do this it already updates it
and does all the stuff behind the scenes
we just need to return this document and
we're done easy enough now we can go to
our document Repository
and here create another function to
update the document so I'm just going to
copy this entire function
let's go down and your paste return so
this is going to be called update
document
here we are going to get the token
along with that we also need the ID and
we also need the title now since there
are three parameters what I like to do
is make them name the arguments so that
it's easier for us I'll just pass in
required everywhere
and then save it Also let's put a comma
here so that the formatting does this
work
all right so we have the error model
there now we will have a response field
post but here it will be
host doc title then we'll pass in our
token because here we have passed in the
auth middleware
then we want our body but in the body
this time we are going to have
we'll remove this line and then we'll
have ID we'll pass in the ID then we're
going to have a title and the title will
be title all of them from the parameters
here
I don't think we even need the update
document part we'll just do it void
because we know there are very less
chances of this not working so I'm just
going to remove all of this I'm not
going to return anything but if you want
you can just go ahead and do the error
handling part it's much better and much
easier and it's good to do always but I
prefer not to do it this time
and it's not update document it's
actually update Title
let's remove this line we'll just do
this part but obviously again I'll tell
you error handling you should do it I'm
not doing it I just don't want to waste
much more time
great now I will go ahead in the
document screen here I'll create a
function to call that method void update
Title we will need widget ref
so that we can call the document
repository so I'll have ref dot read
document repository provider Dot create
or update Title then we need to pass in
the token which is ref dot read
let's find the user provider
and then we'll just pass in the token
and this can be non-nullable because you
are logged in then we want the document
I don't confuse it with the user ID view
on the document ID which you are going
to get from widget.id whatever we are
getting from the Constructor correct
because that's the document ID as well
and then we need the updated title so
that means what do we need to update it
to well we are going to get that
whenever
the user submits this field correct
so what are we going to have well we
will just get the value from your string
title
now whenever the user clicks on enter
that means that the user does this and
clicks on enter then we want the text
field to get updated so for that we are
going to have an on submitted but on
submitted option this will give us a
value so whenever the on submitted part
is triggered what value will we receive
well the entire string there so here
what I'm going to do is call this
function called update Title
pass in the widget ref and the title
will be value great now let's restart
the application
and here I'm going to store it as
titled document
I'm going to click on enter and nothing
really happens if we restart our
application we see nothing so there is
no way of knowing for the user as well
that is it saved so exactly for that we
also need to retrieve the content of the
document so whatever is they pass to it
we want to update it as well whenever we
refresh the document because here I've
passed in the title it's stored in the
database as well I'm very sure about
that right now
but
I want to display it whenever we refresh
or come to this document so how are we
going to do that we're going to go to
the document.js part I'm going to copy
this get route
and then I'm just going to get this
document what is this document well
whatever document we have we want to get
the data of this document so we are just
going to fetch the data by its ID
and then just return it out so here how
do we get the document ID there's no way
because this is a get route get routes
don't have body so how will I access the
ID so for that there is the slug part
now this might be very familiar because
in the router dot dot part we've done
the same thing
as I said the routing part is very
similar no in node.js react how to Dom
everything
so here we have ID now we can access
this ID that's whatever is passed to it
also let's remove this we don't need me
so we have slash docs and then we need
to pass in the ID now to get access to
this ID what we can do is just use
request dot parents
dot ID
with this we have access to the ID of
whatever is passed to it so we are
passing the document ID in the URL of
the route itself because we don't have
access to request.body over here
now what am I going to do will find by
ID
I'm just going to fetch it so this is
going to be a constant
document and then just return this
document easy enough
now again I'll go to my document
repository and I will create the get
function for our content as well
so let's copy this get route
because it's going to be very similar
let's paste it here then we are going to
call this get document by ID then we
want the token and also the ID of the
document
then we are going to do get but here we
are not going to have doc slash me we
are going to have doc at ID
because that's the route right document
and this will make sure that we have
access to request.parents.id
this is basically request dot parameter
if this is like what parameter is passed
to it I call it slug
same thing
then we will pass in the header the
token because you have the auth
middleware then the case 200
but here we don't have a list of
document we just have a single document
so for that what are we going to do well
simple enough it's much simpler than
what we have done before we'll just
remove all the for loops and stuff
also remove all of this
and here we are just going to have
response dot body and we'll pass it in
as the data as well
you can see this looks much much better
document model Dot from Json dress.body
because this will return to us a single
body we have used find by ID not find
this will return to us a list but this
will return just a single document
because IDs are unique in mongodb
we have the default one as well but here
I don't want to throw this error what I
want to say instead is that this
document doesn't exist please tag in
later that's the only possible
conclusion for us because if the user
goes to this route let's say 4 4 then we
want to tell them that yeah this route
doesn't even exist in our mongodb or
it's not accessible to you but
accessible to someone else correct
but that's not the feature we are
looking forward to we're just saying
that this document does not exist in the
entire app so we are just going to throw
an error when we throw an error it goes
to the catch block and here we are
anyways having the error model created
so here I'm just throwing this document
does not exist
that's it
and here let's add another one please
create a new one this sounds much much
better all right
now we can go to the document screen and
here we will call this function in the
init State because whenever our
application reloads we want it to show
that's when init State also loads up
right
so here I'm going to create the function
called Fetch document data
and I'm going to copy this function go
down here I have fetch document data
and here it's going to be asynchronous
now the first thing we need to do is get
the error model and start displaying it
so here I'm going to have error model
error model is equal to await
ref and I need access to ref so I have
to con and we already have that because
we have a consumer State and now I just
realized why do we use error model here
when we also have to use it later on
when using quill controller because the
content of our application will also
change correct whenever we type
something it will start Auto saving it
and it will store to the database even
then the content will also change so we
need it there as well so instead of
creating it like this I'm going to
create it as a variable in this class
so I'm just going to have error model
like this but it will initially be null
correct so that we can distinguish that
the data has come or not otherwise we'll
get late initialization error
now we can do away draft dot read
document repository provider Dot
get document by ID then we need to pass
in the token ref dot read
what is our token well first of all the
user provider which can't be null then
the token and then the document ID which
is widget dot ID
simple
we know all of this now we have access
to error model and we are not creating a
new one so make sure you remove that
because if you put this it will create a
new variable of local called error model
we don't want that we want to set it to
This Global variable
now here we are going to check if error
model
dot data is not equal to null
so I'm making sure error model is not
null because here error model will get
some value
so error model will definitely not be
nullier
but error model dot data can be null so
if it's not null then what do we do if
there is no null that means that means
we have successfully got the document
model that means the correct document
and the data so what we can do is just
use
title controller
dot text is equal to error model dot
data dot title this might not be
accessible here but you can just use as
document model and wrap it with a parent
thesis so that it automatically
identifies and then later on you can use
any of the function correct
so I'm just going to do that and I'm
also going to call the set State
function if I call the set State
function it will rebuild the widget
and after rebuilding it it will show us
the current log or proper title so if I
restart my application
let's see over here I'm still getting
title document
and I just realized why this is not
working I have to remove this
actually let's just go to the localhost
3000
and now you can see title document
showing up which is the updated title if
I click over here it's showing title
document as well if I refresh it again
it showing title document that means
this part is now working with
successfully got the data now the next
part and obviously before going to the
next part let's try it out again
if I restart my browser title document
correct and if I go to the localhost
3000 we have seen that already it
updates the title that's pretty good
anyway so this is a document and we have
done all of that now the next part is
whenever we write over here we do the
collaborative editing part and implement
the auto C functionality for that we
need to jump right into sockets and
we'll start off by understanding what
really sockets are how are we going to
use it in our application and well just
writing the code for it it's pretty
simple let's go so let's start off by
understanding how sockets work I have my
own diagram here so I have my client
server here again a basic back to back
client and server model so whenever the
client sends some information it's
usually only then the server can send
information that's how HTTP request
works that's how we've been making our
rest apis work right we tell them please
send us data server sends us the data
but in sockets what happens is client
says yeah I want a connection
then the server keeps on giving the
connection
and then whenever we again tell the
client that yeah some data has changed
server keeps sending that if we set an
interval server will keep doing that and
you can do it as many types as you want
and it's very quick as well sockets are
designed for this purpose itself it's
it's kind of like a wrapper around so
around HTTP not really but you can
consider it that way it has it is HTTP
but with more features which is real
time so whenever we get some data it's
going to be real time and it will keep
on sending the data to us every bit of
information
so if the client suppose says yeah I
want to start listening to it
so client said I want to listen the
server will send out the data whenever
some data changes we can make sure that
server sends it back to them
correct
but how and why are we using sockets for
like multiple users for example we have
client over here suppose this is another
client and they are all attached to the
same document
so we have three clients who are
attached to the same document for
example this is my iOS phone this is my
web and this is my Android phone they're
all connected to the same document
so first of all we need to make sure
that they are connected to the same
document only then will the sockets work
and they are also obviously having the
same server which is our custom server
but since they've joined the same
document ID we have to make sure that
socket joins their ID they all have
their own sockets correct
so we need to make sure the sockets join
their ID and after which if this client
the web client tells yeah there is some
change please send this to all the user
the server will send it to your ear and
year if it was HTTP and if web send the
server request
server would send it to only this part
only back to the client but with sockets
we can make sure that every client gets
that information if there is a change we
can broadcast it to all three of them
right
but what if I want to send it to only
two of them or only to the ones that are
there in the room or only to the ones
that are not there in the room well you
obviously wouldn't want that but what if
you want to do that well there are many
options on that and we're going to look
into it socket provides all of that to
us
but I hope this simple explanation was
clear if there are three clients if we
use HTTP and if one client sends some
data to the server
it will only be sent back to that user
it won't be sent to everyone in that
room correct but with socket we can send
it to everyone
now how are we going to connect to
socket well for that we are going to
have socket IO client
this is from the client and from the
server side both you can see that we are
sending from the client and we are
getting from the server as well so we
are going to use socket client on both
the sides on which flutter we are going
to use this and with node.js we've
already installed it socket IO 2.3.0
this is very important 2.3.0 as I've
already mentioned it to you you can see
here
Port of awesome JavaScript node.js
library socket IO client version 2.01 to
version 3.03 in Dot we need to use them
as I've used 2.3.0 but there's another
problem with this when I use socket IO
client 2.0.0 I couldn't connect to my
server
there was some issue from uh I don't
know from where and I'm not even sure
why I got I couldn't get it working but
when I lowered down the version it
started working so I'm going to use that
version you can try with 2.0.0 if it
works for you then great if it doesn't
then simply go to your pub spec.tml file
add this dependency but here it will be
the version 1.0.2
make sure flutter prep guide is run I'm
going to close this dot compiler clear
it off and now I'm going to create an
instance of this socket IO client now I
can't just go on and create that
instance in the
document screen well first of all it's
about keeping the business logic away
and second part is that what if I want
to use it in some other screen as well
for example this document screen has
some collaborative editing but I want to
use that in other screen as and when I
expand the app
I won't I won't be able to create
instances of the socket IO client again
and again because socket IO client
doesn't for some reason uh
accept that so we want to make sure that
one single instance of socket IO client
revolves around our entire app so to do
that we are going to go over here in a
library folder and create clients we'll
have our first client called
socketclient.dot and how are we going to
make sure that single instance remains
throughout the class so that we are
going to use
Singleton design pattern so here we are
going to have a class or socket client
then we are going to have socket and we
are going to import it not from dot IO
so let's import it again but from socket
IO client let's remove dot IO
and I'm going to use it as IO instead
so that there is no confusion so I'm
going to have io.socket
which can be nullable socket
then we are going to have a static
instance of socket client
that we can pass from our function
then here we are going to create an uh
socket socket client uh private
Constructor how are we going to do that
socketclient dot internal
will make sure our Constructor here is
private and cannot be initialized now
I'm going to give this socket
the value so it's going to be socket is
equal to IO dot IO that's how you
connect to a URI and then you need to
pass in the URL so for us it's very
simple it's just going to be host
correct
now we can have string
dynamic
and a map that's what it requires also
here let's import our host
so this is how the connection is going
to be done we need to configure the
socket eye socket and then we just need
to call socket dot connect
and it will connect
also this has to be non-nullable
now here I need to pass in some
important functions for example
transports
and this will be websocket we need the
transportation through the websocket and
then we need auto connect set to false
we don't want it to auto connect right
we've always wanted us to connect it
ourselves
then this is the private Constructor
whenever you want it it will be called
and it will connect
and then you also need to provide the
instance correct so how are we going to
do that well we are just going to create
a function for it static socket client
get instance
then we are going to check if the
private variable instance is null then
we want
socketclient.internal we can call this
in the class itself but we cannot call
outside of this because socket client
internal has become a private
Constructor
like private variable
so just in tanks basically means that if
there is no instance and the instance is
null
then we want to create a socket client
internal and
that will make sure we connect otherwise
we will return that same instance
then we can return that instance from
your
also this will be private
and it cannot be null
so this is a socket client package now
after having all of this done we need to
go to our over here and have socket
repository dot dot all of our socket
repository calls or socket calls are
going to be here where we are going to
send to the server just like a vir
document repository and local storage
Repository now before going to the
socket repository let's connect to our
server as well we've connected to the
client now we need to make sure we
connect to the server so that we know
yeah the connection between the client
and the server is successful because we
have passed in the correct Port as well
if we had not passed it there would be
some error
now let's go to the index.js file and
here we need to require constant
first of all HTTP because you want to
create a socket server
then we need to
create a server which will be variable
server equal to
HTTP dot create server
and how we're going to create the server
exactly for that we are going to go down
and do app we need to create the server
with the app with Express so here we are
going to pass in http.create server app
and now we need to do the socket
connection so what we are going to do is
variable i o is equal to require
as you might have guessed socket.io
and this should uh make sure that IO has
some value but here I'm going to even
call the function where we need to pass
in the server which is our server
you can see what we've done is required
socket i o and usually what we do is
socket
and then we store it in another variable
called IO which is equal to
socket like this correct but now I've
done a shorthand Syntax for this and
I've done it this way
great
now I can come over here
below the Mongoose call I'm going to do
it IO
let me have IO correctly dot on
connection so whenever there the
connection is made this is how we listen
to the socket i o calls IO dot on
connection so if the connection is made
with our client side or with any other
client then it will say yeah the
connection has been made and here it
will give access to the socket object
using which we can send data to us
client side as well
so if the connection is made we'll get
access to socket and with this socket we
can send data to our client side
now I can just type console.log
connected just to make sure that we have
connected or not
plus I also want to show you socket.id
this is the socket ID that means every
client that connects to it will have
their own unique socket ID and this can
be accessed using this socket.id even on
the client side we have the socket
client
right even this has their own
client ID if you want to access that
I'll show it to you
but yeah yeah first of all we are going
to have socket Repository
which we are going to create using final
and we are going to have socket client
which is having a private variable which
is going to be equal to socket
client
and you can see I cannot create a
Constructor on it you can see that so
what I'm going to do is dot instance Dot
socket
and it cannot be null because socket
here will never be null because if there
is no value we are not sending any value
but if there is a value
and this value can never be null because
here we are just passing in a null check
operator basically if there is no value
it will run the connect command and it
will connect it and if there is a value
then it will directly return that
if you want to make sure that this
socket client is used somewhere else you
can just create a getter of this so we
have socket client and we'll pass in the
socket client also here the return data
type will be socket now
let's see if this much and see what
we're getting so I'm just going to make
this socket repository call and use this
socket client
I'm going to call this socket repository
so that I get to know if it's successful
or not so I'm just going to do socket
repository socket repository is equal to
socket Repository
and I think this is pretty much it it
should work because whenever I call this
class this is going to get executed and
the connection if it is made then it
should print it out
also here you can see we have some error
over here IO is not defined so we need
to go up here and you can see we are
naming it socket not i o so let's name
it IO and save it now the connection is
successful
and we need to restart our app because
why not then we can sign in with Google
Now I'm logged in so I'll go to the
title document
and
I'm going to do the node server nothing
really gets printed out so
what I'm going to create do is create a
test call and show you a demo of how the
test call will be made
so basically uh whenever we uh let's not
create a test call actually what I'm
going to do is I as I said it to you
socket client has to join a server
so that you know our socket and our
whole server knows our old application
knows that this socket has joined this
is in this room so that we can send some
data to a particular room itself so that
some clients listening to it will get so
for example if there is this server as
well but it's not connected to the same
document as these three clients
so it's connected to the server but by a
different document ID now we don't want
the server to send the the same data
over here as well so how are we going to
achieve that well by making sockets join
a particular room so that a server can
send data to a particular room
so for that I'm going to create a
function called joined room
then we are going to get the document ID
and then we are just going to use
socketclient.mit join and then we need
to pass in the document ID because we
want to join a particular document ID
that is the room ID as well now I can go
to the server and here instead of this
call I can say socket dot on
join so as I mentioned io.on will listen
socketclient.mit then we need to pass in
what is the key like we are emitting
join but
we will have multiple calls in our
application
each call will have a different string
so that would make it easier for us to
uh make our application accessible right
if everyone has the same name then how
do we distinguish between the different
requests sent
and we are sending the document ID so
that we can join the room with that ID
so whenever there is a join we are not
going to get we are not going to get the
socket back here because socket instance
is already there with us we are going to
get the document ID whatever document
that we passed in over here we're going
to get the same data but this doesn't
necessarily have to be document ID this
can be data as well you can call this
anything this is basically a variable
and then we are creating the Callback
function so whenever we get this join
what do we do well we are just going to
use socket dot join method and join to
this particular document ID simple
enough
now I can go to my document screen and
in here I am going to join the
particular room so I'm going to have
socket repository Dot socketclient
actually I'm just going to have socket
repository dot joined row and we need to
pass in widget.id I'm going to do it at
the top before even fetching the
document Data before because later on in
our document data function we're going
to make some uh I think socket calls so
let's have it right at the top so
whenever our web page reloads let's just
join the room
now if I go to this particular screen
let's refresh there is a title document
but we don't know anything because we've
not logged it out so let's say
console.log join
now I'll go to my socket repository
again also restart my app
and again go to the node terminal
nothing really shows up and the reason
it's not working is because if we go
down here
we still have app.lesson but a server is
now This http.create Server so we need
to start listening with this we'll
replace the app with server and now you
can see connected output 3000 joined
connection successful as well
so everything now works we have done the
socket joining part as well
so this is connected now the next part
is whenever we type something we need to
send it to all the the users in this
room how are we going to achieve that
let's understand with the diagram again
I'm going to remove all of this and
let's start fresh so we are going to
have our three clients suppose
we will have 1 2
and 3 clients then we have our server
then suppose this one and let's just
assume all of these documents are
connected to the same document ID and
they are in the same room all right so
now what will happen
this
client will send the data to the server
that yeah I've changed something
so whenever there is some change
we are going to send this to the server
This Server is going to return it back
let me change the color
this will change this color I didn't
know it will change the entire color but
anyways this will change the this will
send it back to all three of them
unless
unless we tell it not to send to this
part because they have already made the
change in their document we want the
change to be made in this one and this
one only
we'll send from this one and they'll
send it to everyone except the sender
because this has already made the
document change for example if I type
over here this has already made the
change in the document correct but the
other two that are connected to this
document haven't made the change yet
so we will send the data to both of them
but not this one otherwise this will
also start typing over here and whenever
they receive the data we'll make sure
that quill we have the coil controller
all right we have this controller for a
reason this quill controller
will take the data and make sure that it
updates the content over here as well
that's going to be very simple for us
but there is a bit of logic there as
well so I'll get to it very soon
so how are we going to write the code
for this well in the socket repository
we are going to create a function
we are going to have void typing so
whenever the user types something we are
going to get typing and this will be map
string dynamic
data
it's going to be of the type map so
whatever data we get is going to be of
the type map and we are going to send it
over because we are going to convert
whatever data we get in the format of
map because it's going to be two things
Delta which is something like a format
so you have text format you have
let's say Json format there is a Delta
format as well with the Delta format we
can we can have multiple things right
for example
bullet points and all of the those stuff
Bolding italicizing with Delta format we
can make sure that we can pass all of
that data to the document or to the
socket or to our mongodb as well
so what am I going to do well
socketclient dot emit simple enough and
then we are going to emit typing this
one was join this one is typing so you
know what to put in the server right
socket dot on typing then we are going
to send off the data this data cannot be
anything other than just one variable
this can be a map
or a string or an end but this has to be
one variable that you're sending across
since I have two variables to pass I'm
converting it into a map format
now I'll go to my index.js file I'll
have socket dot on typing so whenever I
get the typing request we will get two
things well it's just going to be data
for now and whenever we get that data we
are going to do
socket dot broadcast this is something
new
now what is this broadcast broadcast
basically means that the data will which
we are sending to from the client to the
server will be sent to everyone except
the sender itself exactly what we want
if this sender this is the sender then
we want the data to go to everyone
except the sender so that's what
broadcast will do then we can have dot 2
which means we will send it to a
particular room only if we don't add 2
it will send it to everyone be it like a
third client as well which is not
connected to the same client as these
three but is some other document itself
even this but this server will tell okay
you didn't tell me to send it to this
room so I'm sending the data to this one
as well but wouldn't that be confusing
right because this document doesn't even
care about it
so yeah we are we are going to have
soccer.broadcast.2 data dot room
we can access objects using data dot
room and this is what we're going to
pass in we want to pass in the room ID
so that we can broadcast to a particular
room and we are going to send in the
data data which is the Delta so here we
are going to have dot emit and we are
going to have changes so these were the
changes take back your data
after sending it across again I'll do it
on the socket repository part
what am I going to do well I'm going to
create a change listener we have emitted
here but for the first time we are
sending some data from the server to the
client side you can see these arrows we
are sending from the data from the
server to the client side so this client
side has to listen to it as well so we
are going to have void change listener
then we are going to well have a
function here we are going to have
socketclient dot on
changes what is the name your changes so
we're going to have changes and then we
will pass in the data but what data do
we do need to pass in well
we don't need to pass in anything
basically we will send in a function
which will return the map whatever data
we get here it's going to return that
same data so that it can be accessed in
our UI file and make the changes over
there
because we need to compose right so
whatever data we get here we need to add
that to the quill document we can't
access the quill document from our
socket repository so what we're going to
do is accept the function
of maps string dynamic
call that function
and we're going to send that function
across which is data
so basically whenever we get any changes
we are going to get this data we are
going to call this function which has
data map in it
and we're going to pass that out so if
we call this change listener in our init
state in the document screen let's do
that here we are going to have
socket repository dot change listener
and you can see we have something known
as P0 which is basically data so
whenever we are change listener we need
we will pass in some data we will get
some data and with this data what
function do we need to run well we
basically need to tell controller right
now the controller has some value so
right now what I'm going to do is make
this nullable
also remove the final Collier so
basically this controller I'm going to
give it some value after fetching the
document correct
see here I'm just going to have
if the data is not null then we will
have controller equal to
quill dot quill controller
document
okay so we need to pass in the document
now what is the document going to be
well it's just going to be error model
dot data
dot content because it is a document
model dot content dot is empty so if
it's empty if the content is emptied
what do you want because this document
cannot accept
and like it cannot accept empty document
created from the Delta
so here we will just pass in an empty
document
but if the data is not empty then we
need to create this document
from that Delta
and then
how are we going to create the Delta
well we are going to create the Delta
from
document Dot from the Json file not
document sorry we are going to create
the Delta from Json and we're going to
pass in the Json which is error model
dot data dot content
I hope that was clear enough
and you can see even selection is needed
so selection is going to be constant
text selection dot collapsed and we will
pass in the offset as 0.
so here we are basically checking if the
data is not null then the title
controller text should be this and then
we will set in the value of coil
controller to be this so if the content
is not empty right now it is empty so we
will pass in a document which is
empty but if it is not empty then we
will pass in document from Delta and
we're going to create Delta from the
Json file and JS and we are going to
pass in the content but this content we
are sure that it's Json of Delta is
because we are going to store it that
way again now in the change listener
that we wanted to work on
we're just going to use controller dot
compose
so whenever we get some data we want to
compose it right we want to make sure
that controller
can update the document and now after
this we don't need to call set State
because compose within itself calls
notify listeners with notify list nodes
it will notify this coil controller also
here you need to pass in that it's not
null but before that we need to make a
connect correction that if
the quill controller will let's say
controller is not equal to null dead but
if it is null then we want to return a
scaffold
with the body as the loader
also here it will be a constant scaffold
we can go at the bottom pass in
non-nullable now because here if it is
null then we are going to return a
loader now we can go back to the top
here and compose it we know that it will
refresh the a document itself not the
entire widget so we are saved there as
well now here in the Delta it will be
Delta
Dot from and this will be quill dot
Delta Dot from
Json and then we will pass in the data
which is going to be data at Delta
that's how we will send in the
information when we create that function
you will get to know but basically this
is how our data is going to look like as
I said it's going to have two uh
properties Delta and room
so Delta is over here
now the text selection is going to be
controller dot selection
and if it is null then we want to use
our own value constant text
selection.collabs offset 0 and the real
Source here is going to be change Source
dot remote this is going to be very
important in our application also here
we'll pass and quill
this is going to be very essential for
our application I'll let you know why
but basically we've composed this now we
have coil dot change Source dot remote
this can be local as well but this will
be remote I'll tell you why when we
create now the typing function
so now how do we listen to the changes
in our document so whenever I type how
do we how do I listen to it well what
you can do is whenever we fetch the
document
after that we can just have controller
dot document
dot changes Dot listen
and you can see I have the easy ad sets
Whenever there is a change in our
document we are listening to it and we
have access to the event and this event
is a tuple which gives us Delta Delta
and the change source Delta
the first Delta is going to be the delta
telling us the entire new controller
document
so this is the entire content of the
document
then we have second which is the changes
that are made
from the previous
part
basically this is the entire document if
I type like this and then I again type
this
you can see this is the entire content
of the document so it will every time
there is a change Delta the first Delta
in this Tuple will give us this entire
part
but the second Delta will give us only
this s which is the change that is made
and third is the
chain source so what is the source that
had the chain is it local
if it is local that means that we have
typed it over here correct
so we have type but if it's remote when
is it going to be remote whenever we
have composed this
so it's going to be composition from
this change listener so whenever we send
data from here
to our server which will send it over
here
we can compose this data
and send in remote that means that the
document will change again
right so here we are composing it and
when we compose it the document will
again change because this content over
here will change that means this
function will be triggered again because
document.changes Dot listen
I mean it won't happen on this document
but what if we have our second browser
as well we are listening there what we
did was suppose let me just bring it up
I'm going to bring it up like this
suppose I have localhost 3000 here as
well
I'll bring both of them together here
so suppose both of them are linked to
the same file now if I make the change
over here let's say
then it will change over here as well
correct that's how our logic works right
now
but when it changes over here this
document will get notified that yeah
this has changed this will get triggered
then this will again send it to a server
server will again send it to all the
clients that are connected which means
this one and this one will also get the
a
then again the loop will happen this
will send it across over here this will
send it across over here like this and
by just pressing one key of A we have
gotten an infinite Loop now to escape
that we have this
chain source so if the change source is
remote we have passed in over here if
this is remote that means we have got it
from this part that means we just have
to return from this document we don't
have to make any changes we don't have
to send anything to the server again but
if it is local then we want to send it
to the server so let's add that logic
here
well first of all we need to check
if the data dot item let me get this
event
so event.item3 is equal to
quill.chainsource Dot
local if it is local then only we have
to send it to the server so vlab map
string dynamic
map is equal to this
then we can have a Delta Property and in
this Delta Property we can pass in event
dot item two now why are we passing item
2 as I said item 2 will get you the
changed part we don't always want to get
the whole uh
you can say whole text over here because
what if our paragraph gets like suppose
a thousand characters long we don't
always want to refresh thousand
characters when we just type one
character right if I if suppose this is
thousand characters I type this a over
here Q over here
it will rebuild this entire part why do
I do that instead with compose what we
can do if we just go up here you can see
compose
will make sure that it will take all the
item twos basically all the Deltas that
are changed
it will compose them with the existing
deltas
then we are going to pass in the room
and the room is going to be widget dot
ID
and then we are going to Second it
across so for that we've already created
our function socket repository dot
typing and we'll pass in our map as the
data after sending this I can go to my
DOT I can restart now you can see I'm
logged in so if I go to this document
but before going to this document what
I'm going to do is create a new window
altogether where I can test this app
again but since I'm already logged in
from the same device it will think that
I'm logged in so I'm just going to go in
the just guest mode I can't go in the
incognito mode because uh the cookies
will be disabled there I don't want to
disable them and I can't so I'll have
localhost 3000
again I'll have to login over here and
make sure to log in with the same
account that you had registered earlier
on the Google Cloud platform
and I'm logged in you can see there are
no documents over here because I'm using
it for the first time now what I'm going
to do is
create a new document I'm going to make
sure this doc this user also gets to the
same document
now I can type a you can see the change
is there now if you want to see it real
time
I can come over here let me minimize
this out
minimize this also
and here if I type let's say a
I'm getting all of it
if I type in here if I hold it out
italicize it underline it convert it to
a code everything seems to be working so
our part here is done but what if I
refresh my application
you can see it's empty right now but if
I refresh this also it's going to be
empty that just means we haven't started
the auto save feature
now to start the auto save feature what
we're going to do is
create a function for it here in our
socket repository and then finally call
it
so we are just going to have void auto
save
then here we are going to get the Delta
so that we can tell what we need to do
otherwise what we can do is the same map
string Dynamic technique so we can have
map string dynamic
data and we can do socket client dot
emit save
and pass in this data
all right now we need to handle this in
the index.js file so what are we going
to do here we are going to have socket
dot on
save so whenever there is a save call
what are we going to do well we are
going to get the access to the data and
here we are going to call the function
which we are going to create outside of
this so we are going to have constant
saved data is is equal to async we're
going to pass in the data to this
function as well now why am I creating
this extra function because well first
of all I don't want to put asynchronous
over here another thing it just looks
cleaner
here I'm going to have well let document
is equal to a weight and we are going to
call it
document dot find by ID
to see if the data obviously what I'm
going to do well I'm just going to
find the ID I'm going to find the
document so I'll have Delta Data
dot Delta that is going to be the name
of our content and actually here is
going to be document ID because I want
to find the document by its ID so this
will be data dot document ID
then we will have document.content
is equal to data dot Delta
then we will do document is equal to
away document.save
now if you're wondering if you could
have done find by ID and update yes you
could have done but I wanted to show you
the other way you can use find by ID and
update and it should work just fine
anyways we have data.doc ID data.delta
and there is going to be
only two elements just like this one you
know this had data dot this typing one
has data dot content this is has
data.delt if you want you can name this
data.content as well and it should just
work fine but make sure to make the
appropriate changes later on now we are
just going to call the save data
function and we are going to pass in the
data why have I not created HTTP request
for it or the x or the restful API for
it well that's because what if you want
to show like saving or save feature here
we don't have that in our application
but what if you want to show that right
so you can just put io.2 call over here
basically io.2 call will send it to
everyone including the user itself that
yavya made some change this has been
saved
socket.broadcast2 will send it to
everyone except the sender io.2 will
send it to everyone including the sender
and if you wanted to send it to only the
sender then it will be socket.2
or just socket it should just work
but I'm not going to send anything
that simple
now I'm going to go to the socket
repository I don't even have an on auto
save listener call I'll just go to the
document screen
now when do I want to auto save and how
will the auto save feature work well I'm
just going to check my document that
[Music]
in every two seconds I'm going to send
an auto sales auto save request that
yeah it's been two seconds now let's
just update the document two seconds
update the document if you want you can
make sure to update the document in as
much time as you want 5 Seconds 10
seconds 1 second 500 milliseconds
whatever you
wish to it just depends on how many
calls you want to make to the server I
think two is fine it will take user to
take two seconds to just go from here
and then click on back so I think it's a
pretty good thing so here I'm just going
to well leave this part
I'm going to come here I'm not going to
put it in any function because if I put
it in Fetch document data
then it will only run when it's fetching
otherwise in this lesson function which
is basically kind of a stream if I put
it over here you can see this is a
stream subscription if I put it over
here
then whenever the user types only then
will the auto save feature work we don't
want that we want it to work even if the
user doesn't type anything
so we will have socket Repository
Dot
auto save and then we want to pass in
our map what is our map going to be well
it's going to consist of three things
and you can see set cannot be typed so
let's pass in
string comma Dynamic just to tell it
that this is not a set this is a map
all right so what is the first thing
Delta what is the Delta going to be how
am I going to retrieve the Delta now I
don't want Delta of the changes that are
made I want the Delta of the entire
screen to get that I can make use of the
controller given by quill dot document.2
Delta
then I want the room ID so let's see
what I've saved the room ID as
room again so I can just pass in room
widget dot ID and that's pretty much it
it should start saving but you can see
this will run only once only when the NH
State function is run which is in the
start I don't want to save it in the
start obviously so when do how do I make
it run every two seconds so I'm going to
wrap it with timer dot periodic this
timer is given by flutter itself so we
have timer dot periodic then we need to
pass in a duration how many times I mean
and how many seconds should it run so it
will be constant duration pass in the
seconds as
2 and then we are going to have timer
and this is going to be a function so
I'm just going to copy this paste it
down here and save it now you can see
every two seconds this timer will run if
you want you can make this one second if
you want you can make this millisecond
of 500 every 5 milliseconds it will run
but I don't want that I want two seconds
so let's start now obviously we need to
restart so I'm going to restart from
both the sides localhost 3000
over here also localhost
3000 and you can see there is some error
in our server data dot Delta cannot set
properties of null content
so let's go here and see what's
happening the problem is it couldn't
find the proper ID this is
document.fined by iddata.doc ID but we
don't have anything data.doc ID we have
data dot room so we are going to do
data.ru now if we restart you can see it
should work so let me restart my browser
even this should restart
all right so now I'm going to make
changes in title document I'm going to
share the link you know this button is
not working so I'm going to make this
work as well
right now I'm going to send hi
you can see H is now there
I is also there so hey what's uh and all
of this stuff now I'm going to add the
bullet points as well so
thank you
and this will also contribute to the
bullet points
also bold one italicize one and change
the color of one
great now let's try to go back so when I
click here I should go back so how can I
make that feature work
well
we need to go to the document screen and
whenever this button is clicked so
um
this is the button
we just need to wrap it with a widget
known as gesture detector we don't want
ink well because I don't want the splash
effect
we'll have on tap
and we'll just do route master dot route
master
dot of context dot replace the current
screen with Slash so that we go back to
the slash part right
and then we just need to restart when I
restart this the content should all be
the same
but it's not restarting for us
there is some bug with this I don't know
what but whenever I try to do it with
two browsers it always does this so I'm
just going to close this I'm going to
restart my browser I'm going to log in
and see you again we should get our data
saved
and if it's not saved then we've made
some mistake in our code all right so I
have my browsers ready two browsers I
logged out of one so let me sign in
again
now I'll just come over here okay so now
if I go to this title document you can
see all of the data that we wrote is
saved if I take this send it across it's
still saved and if I click over here I
go back to this flash now I just need to
make this Share work how is that going
to work so whenever we click on this it
should copy this to our clipboard so we
have clipboard Dot
set data clipboard data and then we can
pass in the
dot then as well
so what data do we need to pass in here
well it's going to be text and what text
do we want well he DB well basically all
of this
this entire thing
so let's just remove this HTTP then we
will have dollar
widget dot ID
then we have dot then and after dot then
we are just going to have
scaffoldmessenger dot of context dot
show snack bar then we are going to
display the snack bar that yeah this has
been copied link copied
also put a constant there and then just
well this is pretty much it let's try to
restart
if I you know click on the share you can
see link copied if I paste it over here
is the same link and I'll come back over
here if suppose I go on a different
Untitled document and try to type there
the same is not happening over here but
I share the link away from here to here
I mean of course it didn't get copied
but over here if I go
you can see we go back to the assassa
all that part
great so our Docs Google Docs is working
all the displaying part is working and
even it's responsive sometimes not using
media query we can get you responsive
websites as well so this was it for the
tutorial thank you so much for watching
see you in the next video